bonjour à tous bienvenue sur Public
Sénat hier soir les sénateurs ont adopté
le projet de loi sur le Grand Paris par
179 voix pour contre 153 c'est une
version profondément modifié par rapport
à celle adoptée par les députés en
décembre qui a été votée hier soir la
commission mix paritaire chargé de
trouver un texte commun aux deux
assemblées se réunira le 20 mai elle
s'annonce sportive selon les termes de
la sénatrice PS de cénémarne Nicole
brick c'est donc l'adoption de ce projet
de loi que je vous propose de revoir ce
matin bonne matinée à tous sur Public
Sénat la séance est
reprise alors nous reprenons la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée relatif au
Grand
Paris dans la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'article
28 et là je suis saisi de trois demandes
de parole sur article je vais commencer
par Bernard verra
oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le secrétaire d'État
mes chers collègues je souhaitais
intervenir sur cette Antarctique car il
me semble nécessaire d'apporter
certaines précisions s'agissant de la
zone de protection naturelle agricole et
forestière du plateau de
saclé chacun peut se féliciter ici que
la commission spéciale a reconnu à
l'unanimité la nécessité d'inscrire dans
la loi que la zone de protection
naturelle devait comprendre au moins
2300 hectares de terre consacré à
l'activité agricole tout en les
localisant précisément sur les communes
du
Plateau la rédaction retenue par
l'Assemblée nationale entrait en effet
en contradiction avec le consensus
établi localement et inscrit dans le
projet du SDRIF néanmoins le fait
d'avoir sanctuarisé ces 2300 hectares ne
suffit pas à garantir qu'un équilibre
sera respecté sur le plateau entre terre
agricole et zone
urbaines la logique d'urbanisation
massive du plateau que nous craignons
risque malgré tout de s'imposer peu à
peu l'université on doit déménager sur
le plateau de grandes écoles et de
grandes entreprises doivent s'y
délocaliser puis on construira des
centres de vie des logements et des
équipements publics enfin la présence
d'une gare de métro automatique nous
fait craindre le pire quant à
l'urbanisation future à titre d'exemple
nous savons déjà que le déplacement de
la faculté d'orset aura des conséquences
sur la viabilité de la compostière de la
Martinière qui permet de reconvertir les
déchets végétaux des villes alentours
ensuite ce sera le risque d'engrenage
fragilisation des exploitations
agricoles qui ne pourront plus utiliser
le compost fourni sur place nécessité
d'urbaniser autour du métro automatique
augmentation du trafic routier et cetera
au final c'est l'équilibre général des
14 exploitations agricoles du plateau
qui risquent d'être menacé le plan
Campus va consommer 183 haectares plus 9
près de HC sur les 2650 comptabilisés
sur le plateau et il reste donc 160
hectares qui vont être urbanisés
ailleurs mais où et quand ce flou est de
nature a suscité des inquiétudes
s'agissant d'un patrimoine que l'on peut
qualifier d'exceptionnel en particulier
hydraulique grâce à un réseau de Rigolle
et d'Ét éminemment utile pour
l'agriculture la biodiversité la
prévention des risques d'inondation et
bien sûr pour la création d'un réseau de
circulation douce par ailleurs il est
également indispensable de maintenir
l'actuelle diversité des activités
agricoles car nombreuses sont les terres
qui qui sont actuellement utilisés pour
la recherche notamment par l'INRA ce
patrimoine agricole est donc important à
préserver en raison de ses liens avec
les activité de recherche publique or je
ne souhaite pas que de louables
intentions soient inscrites dans le
projet de loi mais qu'ell soi rapidement
oublié une fois la loi votée surtout
quand elles se heurteront à des projets
offrant aux appétits du secteur
immobilier les espace naturel et
agricooles du plateau de saclcly la
préservation d'au moins 2300 hactares
agricoles sur le plateau constitue
indéiablement une avancée néanmoins elle
ne constitue ni une fin en soi ni une
garantie suffisante contre une
urbanisation qui pourrait remettre en
cause le nécessaire équilibre entre les
activités de recherche et d'innovation
et les activités agricoles merci Bernard
verra clairl Campion vous avez la parole
madame la
sénatrice merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet article 28 prévoit la mise en place
d'une zone de protection naturelle
agricole et for restière du plateau de
saccly à statut particulier cette zone
serait entièrement non urbanisable et
les modes d'occupation du sol que ce
soit les usages naturels agricoles ou
forestiers ne pourraiit évoluer sans
autorisation du ministre en charge du
développement durable sur ce point je me
réjouis que la commission spéciale a
réintroduit à l'unanimité le périmètre
sanctuarisé des 2300 hectares de terres
agricoles même si nous restons très
attentifs sur ce point l'agriculture sur
le plateau de saclclet est une activité
majeur consacré par les schémas
d'aménagement successif depuis plus de
30 ans d'ailleurs la présence de la
recherche agronomique travers l'INRA le
CNRS Arvalis et le regroupement
programmé des écoles d'agriculture sur
ce territoire renforce la double
vocation recherche agriculture du
plateau de sacclet la viabilité de
l'activité agricole sur ce territoire a
été déterminé par les pouvoirs public
par la fixation d'une surface minimum de
de 2300 hectares d'un seul tenant
l'adoption de la carte de préservation
de cette terre réservé a fait l'objet
d'un très long travail de concertation
et n'est contesté par personne
aujourd'hui nous évitons le pire mais
cet exemple à travers ce sous-amendement
du gouvernement déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale prouve le peu de cas réservés
à la protection et la mise en valeur des
terres agricoles sur ce secteur par
l'exécutif toujours dans un souci de
cohérence avec l'outil de planification
qui le SDRIF nous vous proposerons
d'exiger la compatibilité de la zone de
protection naturelle à l' agricole et
forestière avec les dispositions du
SDRIF merci et maintenant c'est
Catherine taskaa qui a la
parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le secrétaire d'État monsieur
le Président de la commission spéciale
et monsieur le rapporteur la création
d'une zone de protection naturelle
agricole et forestière dans le périmètre
de l'opération d'intérêt national du
plateau de sacelet répond à la nécessité
de garant ti des terres agricoles sur ce
territoire la proximité de Paris accroit
l'intérêt spécifique de cette zone de
protection naturelle la cohabitation de
territoirees très urbanisés avec ce
poumon agricoles et des espaces
forestiers constitue à l'évidence pour
les habitants de lesson et des ivelines
un élément de qualité de vie et de
protection
environnementale la préservation de ces
terres est bien loin d'être durablement
assuré par la seule définition d'une
superficie de 2300 haectares dont nous
souhaitons bien entendu qu'elle soit
sanctuarisée et qu'en conséquence la
révision du périmètre envisagé à
l'alinéa 13 de l'article 28 ne puisse
pas revenir sur cet acquis conquis de
haute lutte et qui fait vraiment
consensus la viabilité de cette zone
dépendra aussi de sa bonne insertion et
de sa cohésion avec le plateau de SAET
et ses vallées qu'il s'agisse des accès
ou du réseau hydraolique et d'un vrai
travail de prospective sur les mutations
nécessaires des cultures aujourd'hui
quasi exclusivement céréalière comme
vous l'avez rappelé vous-même monsieur
le secrétaire d'État il y a là un sujet
de
concertation jusque- là à peine ébauché
et qui pour être abouti et s
nécessitera un dialogue véritable avec
les collectivités locales et leurs élus
la conformité de la zone de protection
naturelle agricole et forestière avec le
schéma régional de la région
Île-de-France est une nécessité absolu
si l'on veut entrer dans une démarche
réellement
partenariale nous présenterons un
amendement en ce sens qui s'il devait
être rejeté par vous monsieur le
secrétaire d'État état traduirait une
fois de plus votre défiance à l'encontre
des élus locaux de la région le projet
de l'pque du plateau de sacely mérite
mieux que
cela merci Madame la Ministre alors
c'est Catherine wanet qui nous présente
le 273 Dom Dominique pardon oh là à qui
pensais-je à Catherine
taskaa merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames et
messieurs
euh cet amendement donc du suppression
vise en fait à préserver les zones
agricoles et forestières du plateau qui
doit sa richesse à la présence de centes
de recherche et d'établissement
d'enseignement bien sûr mais aussi
d'espace agricooles d'un habitat
diversifié d'un environnement naturel
préservant une biodiversité riche d'un
capital patrimonial important je pense
bien sûr au sititees archéologique mais
aussi au rigol du plateau de sa clé
ainsi qu'aux activités économiques dont
on a dit peu de choses à cet instant qui
existe déjà tant entreprises qu'activité
agricole jusqu'à ce jour les
collectivités les habitants ont
préserver cette zone il est important de
disposer de gardefous pour poursuivre et
amplifier cette protection nous ne
pouvons accepter que l'établissement
public Paris sa clé dont le premier
objectif est le développement urbain et
économique de la zone puisse comme
indiqué à l'alinéa 7 de cet article
inclure des secteurs indispensables au
développement du pôle scientifique et
technologique dans la zone so-disant
protégé n nous opposons donc à des
dispositions à des dispositions
relatives à un soi-disant développement
durable sur un territoire qui jusque-là
n'a guerre eu besoin de l'État pour
gérer ses
richesses merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
euh l'article 28 est un article
essentiel nous en avons convenu lors de
notre
déplacement à sa clé et à orsé et le
fait de supprimer un article qui cré
cette zone de protection serait à mon
avis très mal compris par les
populations riveraines par les les
collectivités locales et par les
agriculteurs et ceux qui s'occupent de
développement durable par conséquent la
commission a émis un avis défavorable à
cet amendement de suppression monsieur
le ministre même avis monsieur le
Président deux avis défvorable il y
a-t-il une explication de
vote alors qui est pour adopter
l'amendement de Dominique
wanet qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté nous poursuivons avec
le
277 Dominique Wanin merci monsieur le
Président il s'agit de faire en sorte
que la zone de protection naturelle
agricole et forestière du plateau que ce
projet de loi en tant créé respecte le
schéma directeur de la région î-de-fance
la aménagement de la région a fait
l'objet d'une volonté de planification
depuis les années d'avant-g guerre quand
l'extension chaotique des banlieux et le
besoin de mettre en cohérence les
multiples éléments du cadre de vie ont
rendu évidente la nécessité de cette
planification d'ensemble la
planification régionale a fourni un
cadre de réflexion et d'action qui a
dessiné le visage de la région il est
peut-être pas utile de remonter à 1965 à
l'élaboration du premier schéma sur la
direction du préfet Paul de l'ouvrier
impulsant la création du réseau express
régional des villes nouvelles et du
réseaux routiers mais face au changement
démographique et socio-économique il a
été revu à plusieurs reprises en 65 pour
loger tous les franiliens et faire face
à la croissance galopante des 30
glorieuses en 76 pour s'adapter au choc
pétroliers limiter l'étalement urbain et
répondre aux préoccupations
environnementales qui apparaissaient
alors en 94 pour rééquilibrer
développement démographique et évolution
de l'emploi vous le savez dernière étape
le projet de sdrift du 25 septembre 2008
euh en 65 le premier schéma directeur de
la région imaginez déjà sa clé comme un
pôle de développement économique il
constitue également un projet d'ensemble
pour les différents acteurs franciliens
nous avons je crois dans les urs n
l'occasion de vérifier la confiance des
francilien dans les dispositifs
régionaux existants nous vous demandons
de prendre en compte ce vote et
d'intégrer la compatibilité de ce
dispositif avec le schéma directeur de
la région
Île-de-France merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président
Monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
euh nous avons déjà jugé à main reprise
la compatibilité avec les dispositions
du chéma directeur de la région de
l'Île-de-France celui qui nous régit est
celui de 94 et celui qui a été adopté
par le Conseil Régional n' pas été
transmis au Conseil d'État il doit être
sans doute modifié or je constate que
sur le fond la rédaction adopté par la
commission qui a supprimé le le terme
choquant environ qui venait de
l'Assemblée nationale et qui a mis au
moins
comment bon il venait de l'Assemblée
allez venez du gouvernement d'accord
d'accord j'accepte volontiers volontiers
votre réaction ENF je l'ai trouvé dans
le texte c'est
uncent de l'assemée nationale oui oui je
l'ai trouvé dans le texte de l'Assemblée
nationale
bon donc
oui
environ c'est mais c'est pour ça que
nous l'avons corrigé donc comme nous
l'avons corrigé et comme sur le fond
l'article 28 prend largement en compte
les dispositions du strif actuel de 94
renouvelé dans le projet de strif nous
émettons un avis défavorable à cet
amendement monsieur le
ministre même avis monsieur le Président
y a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote alors qui est pour adopter cet
amendement
77 qui est contre il n'est pas
adopté Laurent betteille vous nous
présentez le
72 volontiers monsieur le Président
Monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'aurais pu
intervenir sur l'article notamment pour
me féliciter de cette protection qui est
apportée au au plateau de sa clé sur ces
2300 hectares qui sont sanctuarisés je
voudrais d'ailleurs remercier à nouveau
la la commission qui a adopté
l'amendement que je lui avais présenté
ainsi que celui émanant de nos collègues
socialistes qui avaient été rendu
conforme au mien mais ça a permis
effectivement de rassurer
énormément les populations riveraines du
plateau et tout cet ensemble de leson et
des Yvelines et et je crois que ça leur
permet aussi d'obtenir une protection
qui leur faisait défaut depuis très
longtemps parce que indépendamment du
texte qui nous occupe ici depuis très
longtemps il y a un espèce de ggot age
du plateau qui qui existe et qui fait
que ces terres actuellement agricoles
sont en toute
hypothèse par nature menacé du fait de
leur proximité de Paris le fait d'avoir
une protection forte de ces milieux
agricoles est effectivement un très très
gros progrès qui réjouira tous les
défenseurs de l'environnement et qui va
complètement dans le sens de ce qui a
été soutenu par
Nature Environnement et toutes les
associations défense du plateau sur le
plan local et donc c'est une une grande
satisfaction pour autant le souci c'est
une une question de timing et et de
faire en sorte ou ou de de calendrier
excusez-moi pour cet anglicisme malvenu
euh c'est de faire en sorte que rien ne
démarre afin que le décret qui institue
la zone de protection soit pris c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai déposé un
amendement complémentaire qui consiste à
fixer un dél est de 6 mois à compter de
la promulgation de la loi pour que le
décret puisse
intervenir merci qu'en pensez-vous
monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président je je
pense que sur le fond monsieur monsieur
betteille a raison et que il faut que ce
décret lève toutes les les risques
d'obscurité qui pourraient exister ceci
posit quand je lis dans le l'alinéa 5 du
texte le nombre des des consultations
qu'il faut effectuer je me demande si le
délai de 6 mois est est tenable pour le
gouvernement nous vons d'avoir euh un
certain nombre de d'application dans la
loi euh hôpital santé publique
territoire euh où nous il y avait 150
décrets à publier euh et de nombreux
mois après un certain nombre commence à
sortir donc sous réserve que le
gouvernement nous donne son avis euh sur
le fond la commission est favorable le
délai peut-être un peu trop court mais
je souhaite avoir l'avis du Gouvernement
sur ce point monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur bteille le
Gouvernement est favorable à
l'inscription d'un délai dans la loi ce
qui constituera le témoignage de la
force de la réalité d'un engagement qui
a été pris euh tout délai inférieur à 12
moi ne nous paraît pas réaliste enfin je
pourrais expliquer enfin plus
précisément les choses et donc je
souhaiterais que vous puissiez modifier
votre amendement en retenant le délai de
12 mois et le gouvernement serait alors
favorable à votre
amendement alors Laurent
betteille monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre le problème est de savoir
encore une fois je je parlais tout à
l'heure de calendrier à savoir que faut
pas évidemment que démar des opérations
qui remettrai en cause la protection
avant qu'elle n'intervienne dans la
mesure où le gouvernement me donne
l'assurance que rien de tel n'aura lieu
dans l'année qui suivra la promulgation
de la loi je suis prêt à rectifier
l'amendement et à substituer le délai
d'un an à celui de 6
mois vous êtes d'accord
monieurpp alors donc dans un d'un an à
compter de la promulgation de la
présente loi je soumets cet amendement
ainsi rectifié il y a pas de demande
d'explication de vote qui est pour
adopter cet
amendement qui est contre qui s'abstient
est adopté à
l'unanimité merci deux amendements qui
font l'objet d'une discussion
commune qui est-ce qui nous présente
c'est Bernard ver le
oui monsieur le Président je vous
présente peut-être les deux amendements
en même
temps alors ces amendements sont des
amendements de cohérence avec la
position que nous défendons depuis le
début de l'examen de ce texte et qui
vise à renforcer le poids des élus
locaux avec la volonté de promouvoir une
véritable démarche
partenariale les élus locaux sont trop
souvent écartés du processus décisionnel
et subiront au lieu de les élaborer les
décisions d'établissement public à la
légitimité
contestable nous en avons encore
l'exemple avec la délimitation de la
zone de protection naturelle agricole et
forestière du plateau de sacelet cette
zone sera délimitée par décret en
Conseil d'État pris après un avis simple
du conseil régional des conseils
généraux de lesessones et des ivelines
des conseils municipaux et des EPCI la
vie de ces instances élues sera
recueillie au même titre que la l' viis
de la Chambre Interdépartementale
d'Agriculture d'Île-de-France de la
société d'aménagement foncier et de
l'ONF nous proposons donc que l'avis
donné par les élus locaux sur la
délimitation de la zone de protection
naturelle soit un avis conforme par
ailleurs on proposant l'amendement 207
nous pensons qu'il serait souhaitable
que les associations agréées dans le
domaine de l'environnement soitent
associé à la consultation sur la
délimitation de la zone de protection
naturelle en effet elles sont non
seulement directement concerné mais
surtout elle participe déjà activement à
la réflexion sur la protection des
espaces naturels et agricoles du plateau
dans un souci de maintien de l'équilibre
entre ces espaces et les espaces urbains
par conséquent nous souhaitons leur
donner une possibilité de s'exprimer sur
la délimitation de la zone naturelle au
même titre donc que la Chambre
d'Agriculture d'Île-de-France et de la
société d'aménagement foncier de l'ONF
merci monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
sur ces deux
amendements alors je je remercie
monsieur verra d'avoir noté que dans la
rédaction de la Commission on consultait
vraiment la plupart des élus locaux mais
aussi la Chambre d'Agriculture la
Chambre interdépartementale et pas la
chambre régionale la société
d'aménagement foncier l'Office National
des Forêts et bon alors sur le premier
amendement le 206 avis
conforme conformément à la doctrine de
la commission nous émettrons un avis
défavorable sur le de amendement le fait
d'ajouter à l'avis après l'office
national des forêts les associations
agréé pour la protection de
l'environnement présente dans le
périmètre d'intervention la commission a
émis un avis favorable très bien
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président au même avis que le rapporteur
sur les deux amendements je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre y a-t-il
des demandes d'explication de vote alors
je soumets ces deux amendements le 206
de avis favorable qui est pour adopter
cet
amendement qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté par contre le 207 avis favorable
de la commission et du gouvernement qui
est pour adopter cet
amendement je vous remercie infiniment
il y a pas d'abstention il est adopté à
l'unanimité le 175 c'est qui nous le
présente merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur je pense que vous ne serez
pas étonné si une nouvelle fois nous
faisons référence dans cet amendement au
schéma directeur de la région
d'Île-de-France nous pensons en effet
que la qu'il est nécessaire de préciser
que la zone de protection naturelle
agricole et forestière prévue sur le
plateau de sa clé est compatible avec
les dispositions du schéma directeur de
la région
d'Île-de-France vous avouerez que nous
faisons la preuve de cohésion et d'une
certaine logique dans notre discours et
nous pensons en effet qu'une meilleure
insertion du projet dans le droit commun
de l'aménagement régional est nécessaire
j'ai bien entendu monsieur le rapporteur
tout à
l'heure parler du schéma directeur de la
région de France en disant le schéma
directeur en quelque sorte il n'existe
pas il
est quelque part dans quelques
congélateurs il faudra qu'il ressorte un
jour bref il n'empêche que vous n'avez
pas dit monsieur le rapporteur il n'y
aura plus jamais de schéma directeur de
la région d'Île-de-France donc nous
demandons tout simplement quelle que
soit la conclusion qui aboutira à faire
en sorte que le schéma existe nous
demandons à ce que ce schéma soit
respecté par le projet qui nous est
présenté
aujourd'hui merci monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
nous avons tout à l'heure refusé un
amendement de madame voanet qui
comportter la même référence
c'est-à-dire la compatibilité avec le
schéma directeur on ne peut pas à 10
minutes d'intervalle voter la même voter
le contraire de ce qui a été voté tout à
l'heure par conséquent dans le même
souci de logique de la commission nous
émettons un avis défavorable monsieur le
ministre même position monsieur le
Président il y a-t-il une demande
d'explication de vote qui est pour
adopter cet amendement de avis
défvorable qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté Dominique wanet le
oui cet amendement a pour objet euh
d'affirmer effectivement la nécessité de
ne pas procéder au fil du temps à un
efffilochage à un mitage de zones
agricoes euh au motif que les
exploitants qui sont principalement
céréaliés doivent pouvoir fournir une
production rentable de qualité pas
forcément sur la base d'une production
intensive productiviste dirait José
Bovet mais en tout cas une une
production durable grâce à des sur face
stabilisé dans le temps euh
dans le rapport de Monsieur Fourcade on
peut lire que l'agriculture sur le
plateau de sacré concerne environ 3000
hactares de surface agricole dont
quelques 2000 hectares sont contigus au
cœur du plateau euh je conviens bien
volontiers que la disposition arrêtée
par la commission spéciale qui remplace
le terme environ 2300 hactares par au
moins 2300 haectares constitue déjà euh
une amé amélioration tout à fait réelle
du texte j'aurais aimé qu'on puisse
préciser qu'il s'agissait de garantir
l'activité agricole comme l'a d'ailleurs
fait je crois bruneo Lemire en janvier
euh qu'il que que que que cette
disposition donc permette d'avoir des
surfaces suffisantes d'un seul tenant
alors est-ce que 2300 hactares d'un seul
tenant ça existe sur le plateau sans
doute pas je suis tout à fait prête à à
à retirer cet amendement si on me dit
qu'il y a seulement 2000 hectares qui
serait contigu comme le dit votre
rapport monsieur Fourcade mais ce qui
est certain c'est qu'on doit insister
sur le fait qu'il s'agit d'un ensemble
cohérent qui ne doit pas être mité au
fil du temps qui ne doit pas être
l'objet non plus de de coupure par des
infrastructures qui pourraient modifier
le régime d'écoulement des eaux ou la
cohérence des
exploitations il s'agit donc plus d'un
amendement appelant à la vigilance que
d'un amendement à la
robustesse législative
établie monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je remercie madame voanet
d'avoir insister sur la transformation
d'environ au moins sur le problème d'un
seul tenant la la cartographie actuelle
montre que il n'y a pas plus de 2000
hectares contigu et que si on voulait
garantir d'un seul tenant les 2300
hactares il faudrait supprimer des
routes ou modifier ou raser quelques
bâtiments donc ce n'est techniquement
pas possible ce n'est techniquement pas
possible ou alors on supprime des routes
et ayant inaugurer il y a très longtemps
quand j'étais très jeune le chemin de
randonnée et la piste cyclable qui
partait du Crist de sa clé je sais que
si on supprime une route ou l'autre on
pourra arriver à un seul tenant mais on
aura des difficultés de circulation
beaucoup plus importantes donc pour ces
raisons je souhaite que vous le retiriez
madame
VO
Dominique
monsieur le ministre c'est Monsieur le
Ministre
d'abord bien me félicitant de la
formulation adoptée par le Sénat sur
2300 hectares au
moins je voudrais dire à Madame voanet
que enfin comme vient de le dire
monsieur le rapporteur que la réalité
physique le plateau strictou ne permet
pas hein de d'avoir en
continu 2 300 hectar d'un seul tenant
donc effectivement je je pense que cet
amendement pourrait être utilement être
être
retiré alors Dominique wanet
oui monsieur le ministre je je vais le
retirer mais en même temps nous avons en
mémoire suffisamment de situations où
des remembrements extrêmement violents
ont été imposés pour justifier justement
une inentification des pratiques
agricoles pour ne pas admettre que nous
pourrions être responsable de la
suppression de tel ou tel iste cyclable
cher au cur de Monsieur Fourcade euh
simplement vous l'aurez noté tous ces
amendements ont vocation à à vous
prouver que l'agriculture périurbaine
n'est pas une foucade
dérisoire
d'Urbain privé de nature je crois que
dans les années qui viennent on sera
effectivement tout à fait intéressé au
développement d'une agriculture
périurbaine
productive qui permettra d'améliorer le
bilan carbone de la production
alimentaire et qui constituera
effectivement une activité tout à fait
riche en emploi au portes de nos villes
tout à fait
intéressante pour l'alimentation des
populations notre région donc
l'amendement 275 est
retiré nous passons au 208 c'est Michel
Billou qui nous le présente oui monsieur
le président monsieur le secrétaire
d'État mes chers collègues nous
pourrions considérer qu'il s'agit là
d'un amendement de cohérence à celui de
notre collègue bétail que nous avons
adopté à l'unanimité il y a quelques
instants en effet nous proposons que les
communes situées dans le périmètre de la
zone de protection naturelle agricole et
forestière du plateau de sacely dispose
d'un délai de 12 mois et non de 6 pour
mettre en compatibilité leur plan local
d'urbanisme nous entendons ainsi
garantir qu'ell disposeront du temps
nécessaire à une concertation
approfondie avec l'ensemble des des
acteurs et des habitants concernés pour
redéfinir leur plan local d'urbanisme
concernant l'amendement de notre
collègue betteille monsieur le
secrétaire d'État a lui-même indiqué
qu'un délai de 6 mois était difficile à
tenir pour le
gouvernement par voie de conséquence
nous estimons que pour les communes
c'est également le cas au vu de la mise
en compatibilité d'un document aussi
important que le plan local d'urbanisme
tel est le sens de nototre amendement
que nous vous proposons de bien bien
vouloir adopter si possible à
l'unanimité voilà alors Jean-Pierre
Forcade non non non il ne s'agit pas de
la même chose et non d'une part il
s'agissait de la publication du décret
par l'État après consultation non
seulement des élus locaux mais des
organismes extérieurs et des association
là il s'agit de la mise en en en forme
des d'urbanisme ce que nous avons voulu
éviter c'est deux délais de 6 mois il y
a un délai de 6 mois pour l'enquête
publique nous pensons que ce délai de 6
mois pour l'enquête publique peut porter
également sur la mise en compatibilité
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
tenons en rester à 6 mois c'est la
raison pour laquelle la commission a
émis un avis défavorable à votre
amendement merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président malgré
l'excellente présentation qui vient
d'être faite pour défendre cette am
amendement nous partageons cet avis
défavorable du
rapporteur y a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de vote qui est pour
adopter cet
amendement qui est
contre il n'est pas
adopté alors le 278 Dominique
wanet merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement propose de garantir la
superficie de la zone protégée pour
qu'elle soit sanctuaris au maximum
évidemment une terre agricole à 15 km de
la
capitale
suscite des intérêts que personne ne
sous-estime la pression immobilière
pourrait être très forte la revente des
terres agricoles à des promoteurs
pourrai assurer à des opérations une
rentabilité bien plus fort que le
travail des agriculteurs sur place je
suis bien consciente du fait qu'il
n'existe pas de dispositifs permettant
effectivement de protéger aditamam cette
zone vous allez la main sur le cœur
m'affirmer euh que la révision du
périmètre par un décret en Conseil
d'État c'est une oparation fort lourde
que n'importe quel spéculateur honteux
ne pourra pas espérer du gouvernement
qu'il revoit le périmètre à la baisse
euh cela dit il me semble indispensable
de mettre en place des protections plus
durables de cette zone euh comme nous
l'avons fait euh sur le périmètre des
murs à pêches de mon il où plusieurs
dizaines d'hectares sont aujourd'hui mis
à l'abri effectivement des des
spéculateurs c'est le sens en tout cas
de cet amendement merci monsieur le
rapporteur alors monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la Commission ne souhaite pas
donner un caractère
irréfragable et définitif à cette
opération pourquoi parce que dans
l'alinéa 13 de l'article 28 dont nous
discutons
aimablement il est prévu que la révision
du périmètre de la zone est prononcée
par décret en Conseil d'État selon les
modalités définies à l'article L 14415
c'est-à-dire les mêmes modalités de
consultation de l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales de
l'ensemble des organismes et maintenant
après l'amendement de Monsieur verra des
association agréé par conséquent plutôt
que d'avoir un système figé de manière
définitive il nous semble qu'il vaut
mieux s'en tenir à l'alinéa 13 de
l'article et par conséquent la
commission a émis un avis défavorable
mais peut-être pouvezvous retirer
l'amendement au bénéfice de cette
observation monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président je
rejoins les observations faites par
monsieur le rapporteur tout en disant à
Madame voanet que nous le Gouvernement
partage le souci de sansctuariser cet
espace à vocation agricole et naturelle
tout en préservant son adaptabilité dans
le temps
et que nul ne saurait préjuger des
évolutions par exemple lié au changement
climatique et ceci rejoint un propos que
nous avons tenu précédemment sur la
volonté des exploitations agricoles de
pouvoir garder des formes d'adaptabilité
donc nous sommes défavorables à
l'amendement explication de vote
dominiqueanet
oui peut-être aurais-je dû préciser
monsieur le rapporteur que nous excluons
pas du tout qu'on puisse procéder à la
révision du périmètre pour peu que des
compensations soient apportées qui
permettent effectivement de garantir que
le nombre d'hectares agricoles ne sera
pas modifié à la baisse des
modifications oui une suppression de ces
terres agricoles non j'avoue que je ne
suis pas du tout convaincu par
l'argumentation du ministre c'est vrai
qu'on a tendance à mettre le changement
climatique à toutes les sauces moi je
crains et je suis prête à prendre le
Paris
euh qu'il soit plus fréquent et plus
plausible qu'on procède à la révision du
périmètre sous la pression des
investisseurs et des spéculateurs que
sous la pression des agriculteurs qui
voudrai modifier leurs pratique et leur
comportement pour ce qui concerne les
productions avOcatiOn énergétique je
crois que les nouvelles générations de
production à énergétique n'exclu pas non
plus qu'on puisse avoir une sorte de
coproduction on produit à la fois les
aliments et on utilise les chaumes les
pailles et les résidus de la culture à
des avocations énergétiques c'est en
tout cas ce que je souhaite pour le
plateau de sa clé parce que la vocation
de l'agriculteur c'est d'abord de
nourrir les hommes après éventuellement
de produire des succès d'anné au pétrole
à 15 km de Paris si on était réduit euh
à avoir des productions à viser
essentiellement énergétique euh ce
serait quandême un signe de décadence
agricole à laquelle je saurit me
résoudre Laurent betteille
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre notre collègue Dominique voanet
craint la réduction de de la zone de
protection mais il me semble que dans la
mesure où la loi prévoit que celle-ci ne
peut descendre en dessous des 2300
hectares je pense qu'une réduction ne
pourrait intervenir que si la zone de
protection initialement fixé dépasser
ces 2300 hectares et atteignent 2500 ou
2400 tard euh bon moi je crains que si
on on nous dit il y a plus aucune
réduction possible à ce moment-là la
tentation à supposer que le le ministre
et la tentation de vouloir faire une
zone supérieur à 2300 hactares cette
tentation serait sans doute fortement
réfrainée donc je crois que il faut s'en
tenir au texte que nous avons adopté
c'estàd au moins 2300 hactares et et il
me semble queà ce moment-là il y a pas
lieu de craindre une réduction puisque
la loi fixe elle-même le seuil plancher
de cette zone de protection merci il n'y
a pas d'autre demande alors qui est pour
adopter l'amendement 278 de Dominique
Vanet nous avons deux avis
défavorables pour
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté et l'article 28 ASI que l'annexe
abis
amendé deux fois qui est pour adopter
cet article
28 qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'article 28 et
l'annexe abis est adopté nous passons à
l'examen de l'article 29
et comme de tradition je donne la parole
à Madame Clairel Campion merci à nouveau
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la question des transports est
cruciable pour le plateau de saclleet
comme pour l'ensemble de notre région
créer une nouvelle structure un nouveau
syndicat mixte pour faire travailler des
collectivités et des epcies qui sont
déjà engagés dans des schémas et
procédures complexes ne fera qu'ajouter
au manque de lisibilité de ces
dispositifs eux-mêmes plus ou moins
complexe et constituera un frein
supplémentaire à l'élaboration de
schémas de transport enfin adapté au
besoins urgents de la population comme
des euh grandes écoles et des
entreprises récemment la majorité
gouvernementale dénoncer et comparait
l'organisation territoriale de notre
pays à millefeuille il est étonnant de
voir comment aujourd'hui elle se propose
d'en constituer à nouveau un nouveau la
mise en place d'un tel dispositif risque
de plus de constituer une source de
conflit avec le STIF enfin le
gouvernement s'était engagé par votre
intermédiaire monsieur ministre devant
l'Assemblée nationale a retiré cet
article dès lors que la procédure de
mise en place d'une délégation de
compétenence relative au transport était
engagé sur le plateau de sacclet mes
collègues et moi-même avons porté à
votre connaissance la délibération du 17
février 2009 prise par le conseil du
Stiff qui engage bel et bien une telle
procédure cette
délibération a d'ailleurs été adoptée
avec une très large majorité des voix
par courrier du 23 février 2010 le
président du conseil régional vous en
informait et précisait que des premiers
échanges entre le stitif la Communauté
d'agglomération du plateau de saclclet
et l'ensemble des collectivités
concernées par ce projet notamment la
communauté d'agglomération euressonne la
communauté d'agglomération versailles-
grandr-pis et la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline permettait de dessiner les
conditions d'un d'une telle
délégation la décision sera for
formalisé au début du mois de juin
prochain lors d'un prochain conseil du
STIF la détermination dans la mise en
place de cette délégation ne peut être
nié c'est pourquoi nous vous demandons
de supprimer cet article merci clairl
Campion alors deux amendements
identiques qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune c'est Nicole brick
qui nous présente l'amendement
16 ah Monsieur le Ministre
cette rédaction et cet article pour tout
dire 29 nous fâche beaucoup nous l'avons
annoncé au début de l'examen de ce texte
nous considérons que le maintien de
l'article 29 et fait partie de la
trilogie de la déclaration de
guerre que vous avez fait avec l'appui
de la majorité sénatorial à l'encontre
de la région
île-de-fance autorité
organisatrice des transports et au
travers du STIF alors peut-être
pourriez-vous avoir l'occasion à la fin
de ce texte de sortir de cette logique
de confrontation que finalement vous
aveit recherché et qui nous promet une
commission mixte paritaire assez
difficile avec nos collègues députés
parce
qu'effectivement
madame Campion ma collègue de lesson a
par avance défendu l'amendement de
suppression euh que nous proposons au
travers de l'amendement
176 car il nous semble que vous étiez
engagé à l'Assemblée à retiré cet
amendement si le Steve prenait une
délibération pour organiser la
délégation de compétences euh alors en
commission spéciale le rapporteur nous a
dit on peut pas se satisfaire de d'un
d'un vague engagement ce n'est pas un
vague engagement c'est une série de
décisions qui ont été prises et j'y
reviendrai dans l'explication de vote
mais franchement il serait bienvenu de
retirer en séance cet article ça
montrerait monsieur le ministre et et
chers collègues de la majorité que
conformément à ce qu'avait dit notre
collègue d'allier qui nous est revenu ce
soir peut-être que il va animer un petit
peu la soirée parce que en son absence
ses collègues ont quand même été assez
tristes ils n'ont pas participé à la
discussion en tout cas ils ont été meés
dans la mesure où
effectivement pourquoi chercher à tout
prix la guerre on peut peut-être
l'éviter dans l'intérêt des franciliens
et en l'occurrence de de nos
compatriotes de les son des Yvelines et
de du d'une partie aussi du valdoise
donc c'est dommage si vous ne le faites
pas et à ce moment-là on
examinera l'amendement de repli mais je
vous donnerai dans l'explication de vote
un certain nombre de faits précis qui
montre
que la région ce n'est pas un vague
engagement de sa part c'est une
réalité Bernard verra vous nous
présentez le
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
secrétaire d'État mes chers collègues
l'article 29 pose deux types de
problèmes en effet en créant un syndicat
mixte de transport dont la compétence
sera limitée au plateau de sacelet il
remet en cause une organisation
régionale des transports actuellement
gérée par le
STIF cet article traduit encore une fois
votre volonté de remettre la main sur la
région d'Île-de-France en proposant de
démanteler un organisme qui certes doit
être renforcé dans ses moyens et dans
son fonctionnement mais qui a procédé à
des investissements massifs pour
améliorer les transports en
Île-de-France le problème des transports
et des déplacements domicile travail est
une préoccupation majeure pour les
franciliens et les dysfonctionnement
liés à la vitusité du réseau sont trop
nombreux allongeant des temps de trajet
déjà importants en raison de
l'éloignement du domicile et du lieu de
travail l'urgence à rénover le réseau
des RER B et C et à renforcer le
maillage des transports sur des
territoires aujourd'hui isolés n'est
plus à démontrer c'est pourquoi nous
défendons de façon constante dans cette
hémicycle ou par le biais de nos
collègues conseillers régionaux un
renforcement du STIF et de ses missions
afin de renforcer la cohérence du réseau
de transport sur l'ensemble de la région
Île-de-France nous nous contestons par
conséquent le morcellement du STIF tel
qu'il est prévu par cet article ce qui
m'amène au deuxième problème posé par
cet article et qui a été évoqué par nos
collègues socialistes les débats ont
effectivement en commission rappelé que
le STIF avait adopté une délibération le
17 février dernier afin d'organiser une
délégation de compétences relative au
transport sur le plateau de saclcly et
rendant donc inutile la création d'un
syndicat mixte de transport par ce
projet de loi pour les raisons que je
viens d'évoquer je tiens à préciser que
cette décision a été adopté sans les
voix des élus communistes de la région
qui se sont opposés à ce transfert de
compéten pour des raisons deux principes
tenant d'une part à la nécessité de
préserver l'intégrité des prérogatives
du STIF et d'autre part la nécessité de
promouvoir l'égalité des territoires et
l'égalité d'accès des Franciliens au
service public de transport enfin notre
opposition tient également au fait que
la création d'un syndicat mixte de
transport sur le plateau de saclet
constituerait une première étape dans le
démantelllement du STIF puisque chaque
futur pôle pourra créer un syndicat
mixte de trans transort sur son
territoire nous aurons donc une
multitude de d'autorités organisatrices
de transport sur le territoire franilien
ce qui aura pour conséquence de briser
toute volonté d'assurer une cohérence
territoriale au schéma des transports en
Île-de-France au détriment bien
évidemment du stifff et évidemment
allant à l'accentuation des inégalités
entre les territoires et les populations
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis sur
ces deux amendements identiques monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues voilà deux amendements
qui proposent la suppression de cet
article qui est tout à fait cohérent
avec la création de l'établissement
public et qui je le précise tout de
suite ne remet pas du tout en cause l'
missission du STIF car il lui permet à
tout moment de reprendre la main en
effet en effet j'ai proposé à la
commission spéciale un amendement
qu'elle a accepté qu'on va voir tout à
l'heure pour que le syndicat mixte de
trans prévu par l'article 29 ne soit
institué qu'à comptter du 1er janvier
2011 ce qui permet d'ici là au sttif de
créer de sa propre initiative une
véritable autorité organisatrice de 2e
niveau et deuxièmement si d'aventure le
STIF ne créit pas cette autorité
déléguée la l'alinéa 15 du présent
article permet au Steve de reprendre la
main car s'il approuve le plan local de
transport qu'a élaboré le syndicat mixte
c'est lui qui organisera les transports
et le syndicat mixte disparaîtra
purement et simplement par conséquent
euh cet article 29 n'est absolument pas
une reprise une démolition une un
démantellement du STIF j'ai à titre
personnel une expérience des délis de
décision du stitif que je ne rappellerai
pas ici puisque c'est personnel mais je
je considère comment c'est pas du tout
avant non non non c'est pas du tout
avant c'est maintenant j'ai une
expérience des délais extraordinaires
pour arriver à prendre une décision au
sttif et par conséquent je crois qu'il
est bon de lui donner un délai pour agir
par conséquent avis défavorable sur les
deux
amendements merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
Président je vais répondre et à Madame
brick et à Monsieur
verra en disant tout particulir madame
BRI j'ai entendu non seulement dans cet
hémicycle
mais dans la
presse des des des propos
guerriers sur une déclaration de guerre
et cetera et cetera bon écoutez je crois
qu'il faut rester un tout petit peu
lucide et
tranquille mais c'est pas ce qu'il a
fait de mieux voilà mais il a repris
effectivement des propos il a il a il a
oui il a il a repris des propos monsieur
café qui ont été effectivement utilisés
dans ce Dom enfin je veux dire que en
peut mais écoutez on peut jouer à ça si
vous le voulez mais c'est pas c'est pas
c'est quand même pas l'objet je crois de
ce cet article 29 je crois qu'il faut
voir les choses plus calmement le
problème est un problème de respect
d'engagement qui ont été pris alors
puisque dans ces choses-là il faut être
précis je vais l'être
bon
vous le savez ainsi que Monsieur l'ami
député du plateau de saclé et d'autres
élus nous avons demandé autif de créer
une autorité organisatrice de transport
de second rang dans la zone du plateau
de saclé et c'est ainsi que j'ai été
amené à déclarer le 27 novembre
2009 lors du débat à l'Assemblée
nationale
que depuis déjà de très nombreux mois
car en effet cela faisit de nombreux
mois Mo que l'on demandait à la région
de bien vouloir mettre en place cette
autorité nous avons demandé au sttif
d'envisager la création d'une autorité
organisatrice de transport de 2e rang
sur et autour du plateau de sa
clé comme Madame le petit disais-je qui
était présente dans l'hémicycle la
rappelé le STIF s'est
engagé à créé début janvier début
janvier nous étions donc en novembre
début janvier de cette
année cette autorité organisatrice des
transports le gouvernement disais-je
maintient sa position sur l'article
29 si nous constatons la réalisation de
l'engagement pris par le
sttif tous les élus et la population
attendent la création de cette autorité
de transport le gouvernement retirera
l'article 29 voilà très exactement la
déclaration que j'ai faite à l'Assemblée
national lors de son audition par la
commission spéciale le président du
conseil régional a indiqué et je cite le
compte-rendu de cette
audition concernant le développement du
plateau de saclé le conseil
d'administration du STIF examinera le 7
février
2010 le projet de création d'une
autorité organisatrice de transport
déléguée sur cette zone répond ainsi aux
préoccupations traduites par l'article
29 du projet de loi
or la délibération numéro
200160 a donné mandat à la directrice
générale du STIF pour examiner les
conditions d'une délégation de
compétence sur le territoire du plateau
de saclclé avec la communauté
d'agglomération du plateau de sa clé et
l'ensemble des activité concerné par le
projet sur cette base la directrice
générale du STIF proposera au Conseil un
mandat de
négociation en vue de la conclusion
d'une convention avant l'été 2011
bon ce sont des des des faits des propos
tenus bon nous considérons que cette
délibération ne répond en rien à
l'engagement pris et donc de notre avis
il n'y a pas lieu de supprimer l'article
29 nous sommes actuellement sur un
amendement de suppression d'article nous
verrons plus loin dans la discussion
s'il convient en effet dans un esprit je
dirais de d'apaisement et et de
complémentarité d'imaginer un dispositif
qui permettent à la situation de
progresser donc pourst monsieur le
Président je suis en en défaveur de ces
deux
amendements merci alors y y a-t-il des
demandes d'explication de vote Nicole
brick
oui moi je voudrais aussi rappeler en
explication de vote un certain nombre de
faits très précis qui qui atteste de la
maturité des collectivités locale
intercommunale du plateau de sa clé et
territorial en la matière la région
Île-de-France et son autorité
organisatrice le STIF d'abord il faut
rappeler que dès
2008 les élus des collectivités
concernées ont pris l'initiative de
créer une agence d'urbanisme et de
développement durable ça atteste de leur
capacité assurer la coordination du
développement de du territoire concerné
cette agence est présidée par François
de Maier présidente de Versailles Grand
Parc deuxièmement le STIF n'a pas
attendu le 17 février pour se mettre à
la tâche il a
procédé depuis 2009 à la renégociation
avec les opérateurs de l'ensemble des
contrats de transport routiers de
personnes et elle a déjà porté sur une
vingtaine de réseaux et les
collectivités en en l'occurrence les
communautés d'agglomération de
saint-quenttin en iveline du plateau de
saclé de Resson et de Versailles
grandpque ont été pleinement associés
aux négociations des contrats
d'exploitation j'en veux pour preuve que
le contrat d'exploitation du réseau
versaill grand parc le chaînet a été
approuvé par le conseil d'administration
du STIF dès le 9 décembre 2009 le
contrat de réseau plateau de sa clé EUR
et son doit pour sa part être soumis au
Conseil qui qui précède les vacances
d'été troisièmement le Steve propose aux
collectivités pour chaque bassin de vie
et j'insiste sur la notion de bassin de
vie parce que il y a aucune ligne de bus
qui s'arrête à des frontières
administratives qu'ell soit celle des
collectivités ou celle des départements
donc ce n'est pas simple pour arriver à
effectivement à créer des autorités
organisatrices de proximité et elle
propose le Steve propose une convention
partenariale et ces conventions
partenariales préfigurent la délégation
de compétences aux collectivités
signataires qui le souhaite c'est comme
cela que le projet de convention est
finalisé avec la communauté
d'agglomération 51 en Yveline et qu'au
fur à mesure les autres collectivités
vont signer ces conventions partenarial
mais ça demande du temps de la
négociation qui est qui va beaucoup plus
loin qu'une simple
concertation le développement de l'ofre
de transport là aussi c'est une
négociation c'est une discussion qui
doit être faite sur l'ensemble du
territoire visé par l'article 29 du
projet de loi plusieurs décisions déjà
été pris la commission d'offre de
transport a décidé le 1er décembre 2009
d'un renfort de 11000 km par an sur la
ligne orsé bururivette et de 20200 km
par an sur la ligne saclelé Les Ulis ces
renforts d'offre ont été mis en place
dès le 1er janvier 2010 donc bien avant
la décision de mandater la directrice du
général du STIF pour arriver à conclure
une une autorité organisatrice de
proximité donc tout cela se fait sans
sans la loi sans votre article 29 et en
ce qui concerne le mandat qui a été
donné à la directrice générale sous
l'autorité du
président de de la région île-de-fance
d'examiner les conditions de délég d'une
délégation de compétence sur ce
territoire moi je voudrais insister sur
le fait que ça ne peut pas se faire du
jour au lendemain parce que il faut
consulter négocier et qu'il n'est pas du
tout dit au jour d'aujourd'hui avec les
contactes qu'à la directrice générale
avec l'ensemble des collectivités que on
aboutisse à une seule autorité
organisatrice c'est pas du tout assuré
parce que bon il peut y avoir il peut y
en avoir quatre finalement autorité
organisatrices de proximité parce que on
discute on négocie avec les
collectivités et avec avec les
représentants des territoires ce qui est
sûr pour terminer monsieur le secrétaire
d'État c'est que le 2 juin c'est la date
du prochain conseil d'administration du
STIF un rapport d'étape sera fait sur
l'ensemble de ces
négociations conformément au mandat qui
a été fixé à la directrice générale à ce
moment-là on verra effectivement si on
avance dans fermement mais je je crois
que les faits que je vous ai rappelé
vous pouvez pas les contester donc il y
a un travail qui est qui est énorme qui
demande du temps parce que il faut
prendre la tâche des collectivités
locales alors ça c'est pas votre
problème
mais pensez que ça peut être celui de du
conseil régional et ça peut être celui
de du stitif
donc même si vous mettez un délai comme
vous souhaitez le faire bon qu'est-ce
qui se passe qu'est-ce qui se passera
monsieur le secrétaire d'État si
Infiné on n arrive pas l'état siègera
tout seul c'est ça c'est ça que vous
voulez bon
donc je sais pas faites un petit peu
preuve de bon sens vraiment là je fais
pas d'idéologie vous savez très bien que
ce sont des process longs compliqués et
bon on est attaché à la démocratie
locale c'est comme ça bon c'est
peut-être pas votre problème c'est le
nôre Jean-Pierre
café
merci monsieur le Président et très
rapidement en complément de ce que vient
de dire Nicole brick qui a été
extrêmement précise en fait à la fois
sur le processus qui a été engagé par la
région et aussi pour sur la difficulté
en fait à arriver à la création de cette
autorité de second rang moi simplement
ce que je voulais dire bon c'est que
nous sommes à l'article 29 le dernier
article de ce projet de loi et pour la
dernière fois je dis la dernière fois
parce que c'est le dernier article de ce
projet mais aussi pour la première fois
et je dis la première fois parce que il
ne l'a jamais fait jusqu'à présent
monsieur le secrétaire d'État aurait pu
faire un geste vis-à-vis des
collectivités territoriales et vis-à-vis
de leur
représentation légitime et leur
émanation tout aussi légitime je parle
notamment du STI et ce geste une
nouvelle fois est refusé
que après avoir interdit à la région de
mener un débat public sur ses propres
projets lesquels je le répète au passage
monsieur le secrétaire d'État j'y
reviendrai peut-être tout à
l'heure sont financés eux après avoir
interdit à la région par un
amendement de mener un débat public sur
un projet qui a été je disait financé
mais délibéré par l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales et y compris
par les appartement voilà aujourd'hui
qu'on nous dit nous avons demandé à la
région de faire quelque chose la région
le fait a pris une initiative et bien je
ne la crois pas et depuis le début de la
discussion de ce projet de loi que ce
soit à l'Assemblée nationale ou que ce
soit au Sénat nous avons une asymétrie
quand le secrétaire d'État nous dit
quelque chose c'est plutôt rare c'est
plutôt rare il faut lui le croire sur
parole bien évidemment quand la région
ou une collectivité territoriale prend
une initiative ou des décisions qui ont
été délibéré
ou là là mais attendez mais vous êtes
sûr que cette initiative bon est-ce
qu'il faut y croire et et depuis depuis
le début de la discussion de ce projet
nous nous heurtons à une espèce de mur à
cette asymétrie consistant à dire je
représente l'État j'ai raison vous
n'avez qu'à vous plier à ma volonté je
le répète c'était la dernière fois et la
première fois que le secrétaire d'État
et le gouvernement pourrait faire un
geste il ne le fait pas je vous le dis
monsieur le secrétaire d'État ça augure
mal de l'avenir de votre projet merci
madame la Présidente Nicole borveau vous
avez la
parole merci je vais être très Brè bon
on fait le constat qu'encore une fois
vous niz euh la réalité locale et euh
les droits des collectivités
territoriales et en l'occurrence qui
plus est du STIF mais euh vous avez
indiqué monsieur le secrétaire d'État
que vous verrez dans une discussion
ultérieure alors euh il serait bon de
préciser à de quelle discussion
ultérieure euh vous parlez puisque là
nous sommes en train de légiférer vous
voulez faire vous voulez faire inscrire
dans la loi cet article 29 qui
visiblement entend faire comme si les
collectivités n'existaient pas et en
plus si elle n'avait aucune prérogative
en la matière et vous nous dites que
vous remettez ça à une discussion
ultérieure alors est- une discussion
avec les collectivités territorial en
fonction de quoi on aimerait bien avoir
quelques précisions en tout cas
effectivement le fait que vous vouliez
absolument maintenir cette ma mise en
quelque sorte de l'État ou cette
défiance de l' état vis-à-vis des
collectivités n'est pas de bonne augure
pour la réalisation de votre
projet
merci alors je vais soumettre au vote
ces deux amendements identiques qui est
pour adopter ces deux amendements de
suppression qui est
contre ils ne sont pas
adoptés
nous poursuivons avec trois amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune et je vais demander à Monsieur
Fourcade de nous présenter le
304 alors monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues mon
amendement 304 a pour objet d'enlever du
paragraphe 23 du texte et et également
en l'alinéa 13 le mot intégralement
parce que si on subordonne l'entrée en
vigueur de ces soit du syndicat soit de
l'autorité à la au fait qu'on assure
intégralement la desserte et des
organismes exerçant des activités on
risque d'avoir un blocage parce qu'il y
a toujours un établissement
d'enseignement ou un organisme qui ne
sera pas desservi donc je trouve que si
on met dans le texte d'assurer la
desserte c'est largement suffisant et le
mot d'intégralement risquerait de
entraîner un blocage c'est pourquoi je
propose qu'on le supprime et à l' Linéa
13 et alignéa 23 du présent
article merci qui est-ce qui nous
présente le
177 c'est Nicole
brick c'est Nicole brick c'est un
amendement de
repli par rapport à la date à la
condition suspensive qui a introduite le
rapporteur euh bon nous je crois que le
rapporteur il il
voulait le 1er janvier 2011 je crois et
nous nous proposions avant l'été 2011
mais l'été commençant je crois le 21
juin euh le secrétaire d'État nous a
fait remettre en séance tout à l'heure
un amendement qui va jusqu'au mois de
juillet donc euh
bon monsieur le
ministre vous vous présenter le 306
oui euh au moment
où notre débat est en train de s'achever
sur euh ce projet de
loi je voudrais
dire un certain nombre de sénatrices et
de
sénateurs
que je me souviens fort bien il y a
maintenant quelques semaines dans la
déclaration générale que j'avais faite
en introduction nos débats j'avais
insister sur le fait
que il devait y avoir
complémentarité
entre les compétences d'intérêt national
qui sont décrites dans cette loi et qui
vont permettre
de
réaliser pour une part
importante ce projet du Grand
Paris qui est un projet je j'insiste
encore c'est un projet qui n'est pas un
projet parisien qui n'est pas un projet
régional qui est un projet d'intérêt
national bon il n'est plus l'heure de de
discuter de tout ceci enfin j'espère que
ça a été
entendu et des compétences
régionales et j'ai affirmé à plusieurs
reprises sans jamais avoir été démenti
ni à l'Assemblée nationale ni ici même
sur le fait que les compétences
régional telle que définie par la loi
n'était pas concerné
par ce projet de loi et qu'il y avait un
respect des compétences régionales
bon si effectivement certains en doutent
encore et si par hasard il était appelé
au Conseil constitutionnel de trancher
je peux vous dire que nous avons examiné
très précisément cette question depuis
fort longtemps et que nous n'avons pas
grande inquiétude là-dessus
bien non je lis la presse
madame brick a alors je vais je vais je
vais vous dire que je voudrais conclure
ce débat en ce qui me concerne par mon
point d'entrée dans le débat à savoir
que ce que nous devons rechercher c'est
la complémentarité des
efforts et en ce qui concerne cet
article 29 bon tout à l'heure j'ai bien
entendu madame brick
en fait mon sentiment c'est que depuis
des années enfin depuis que la loi sur
les transport en Île-de-France a été
créé il y a une volonté qui est de ne
pas créer d'autorité organisatrice des
transports de 2e rang ceci a été vrai
pour Paris pendant plusieurs années et
cela est vrai actuellement dans des dans
des des des objectifs comme ceux d'une
autorité organisatrice transport sur le
plateau de sa clé alors madame brick en
faire quatre sur le plateau de sa clé ça
veut dire ne pas en faire du tout non
non non mais mais mais non mais non ce
sont pas les collectivités écoutez les
collectivités
locales je crois je crois être au
contact au moins autant que certains ici
ils aspirent à quoi à pouvoir
effectivement circuler hein sur ce grand
plateau de sa clé et autour et
effectivement il faut une autorité
organisatrice de transport et d'ailleurs
le président de la région n'a pas remis
en cause le principe ce à quoi on est
confronté c'est un problème de
délai alors comme c'est un problème de
délai et que vraiment c'est pas la
recherche la recherche de l'affrontement
c'est tout à fait le contraire
effectivement je propose un amendement
hein je propose un amendement
qui veut bien prendre considération que
c'est un peu difficile mais alors
écoutez si ça c'est difficile faire une
infrastructure de 130 km de réseau
automatique en 10 ans 13 ans en
Île-de-France ou en région capitale
c'est infiniment plus
difficile mais mais écoutez je sais pas
écoutez je sais pas si c'est très fort
mais au moins on prend l'engagement on
prend on prend l'engagement devant vous
tous de de de le faire je dis simplement
je dis simplement que refaire une
autorité organisatrice de transport sur
le plateau de sa clé en disant que c'est
très difficile à faire que ça demande
beaucoup de délai et le fait de nous
opposer qu'on ne saurait pas faire une
infrastructure de métro automatique qui
sera dans un premier temps exceptionnel
au monde enfin il faut il faut que l'on
pèse il faut que l'on pèse mais bien sûr
qu'on verra bon mais il faut que l'on il
faut que l'on pèse les choses alors ce
que je propose puisqueeffectivement
c'est un peu difficile et je veux bien
le croire c'est que
nous modifions si vousêtes d'accord
monsieur le rapporteur à l'alinéea 23
les mots avant le 1er janvier 2011 par
les mots avant le 1er juillet 2011 c'est
qu'on donne effectivement 6 mois
supplémentaires pour que la directrice
générale du stitif puisse mener à bien
cette opération parce que ce n'est pas
une atteinte aux prérogatives des
collectivités territoriale elle le
demande et il suffit d'aller sur le
plateau de sa clé pour savoir que tous
les chercheurs le demandent tous les
enseignants le demandent tous les
étudiants le demandent je crois que il
est notre responsabilité à nous tous de
pouvoir répondre le plus rapidement
possible au fur et à mesure du
développement du plateau de sa clé à
cette demande basique c'est
tout
merci alors monsieur le rapporteur quel
est votre avis sur l'amendement
177 alors monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues sur
l'amendement
177 je note qu'il comporte le mot
intégralement dont j'ai demandé tout à
l'heure la suppression et que sur le
plan du délai il est d'accord avec
l'amendement du Gouvernement qui va dans
le même sens
ou le gouvernement est d'accord avec
vous allez d'accord le gouvernement est
d'accord avec vous allez et par
conséquent la commission n'a pas
délibéré sur amendement du gouvernement
mais avec l'autorité bienveillante du
président à titre personnel je lui donne
un avis
favorable et donc favorable sur l' vie
sur
le très
bien c'est
la
alors monsieur le ministre à vous sur le
304 même avis que le
rapporteur d'accord
favorable sur le
177 qui a été présenté par Madame
brick
défavorable monsieur le ministre
d'accord et voilà
non
défavorable
voilà
allez donc sur l'amendement on passe au
vote il y a-t-il une demande
d'explication de vote sur
304 c'est celui de Monsieur
Forcade donc avis favorable c'est celui
de la du rapporteur avis favorable du
gouvernement qui est pour pour
l'adopter qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté celui de celui-ci tombe le
177 oui il est
satisfait l'alinéa 23 et nous en
arrivons au 306 qui est l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui repousse la date au 1er
juillet
2011 alors Monsieur de cessar Nicole BRI
Jean-Pierre café non ah je croyais
alors Monsieur le avant le dîner nous
avions posé une question sur la fac
enfin non l'université d'ors qui serait
déplacé de quelques centaines de mètres
parce que c'est important qu'elle soit
au cœur du plateau ou tout se passe je
remarque d'ailleurs que Stanford et la
vallée du silicium en Californie c'est
beaucoup plus que quelques centaines de
mètres mais bon vous décidez de changer
de PLACE l'université ça coûte cher mon
collègue communiste monsieur Veral l'a
signalé le double et bien sûr que les
gens sont contents puisque on fait rien
depuis 10 ans et là on leur dit vous
aurez tous des bâtiments neufs super
donc évidemment entre avoir des
bâtiments qui se dégrade depuis 10 ans
et la possibilité dans 5 ans d'avoir des
bâtiments neufs c'est disons que c'est
un choix qu'il est assez facile de
deviner la fin
l'aboutissement mais à ce moment-là vous
avez dit Monsieur Desessard je vaux vous
faire une une fleur je vous en remercie
j'aime bien les fleurs et vous avez dit
je vais vous
répondre sur le fait que il y avait une
gare
RER aujourd'hui pour desservir
l'université donc il y avait une belle
université deux gares RER en bas là du
plateau deux gares R et vous la déplacz
et maintenant les étudiants qui sont
chargés de se voir de de communiquer de
se déplacer facilement parce qu'ils ont
tellement de choses importantes à faire
ils vont être loin du RER des deux gares
bon et vous nous avez dit oui monsieur
Desessard c'est à l'article 29 je vous
répondrai à ce moment-là pour dire
comment vous allez faire pour que la
construction de cette université
nouvelle corresponde avec l'arrivée des
gares erur il y aurait ri rien de plus
stupide que déplacer une université qui
a aujourd'hui deux gares R pour la
mettre sur le plateau où il y a aucune
gare bon donc vous allez certainement
nous expliquer comment vous allez faire
en sachant que le début quand même du
tunnel c'est le valde Marne j'avais cru
comprendre la semaine dernière enfin il
y a 15 jours vous est-ce qu'on peut
savoir comment vous allez faire pour que
ces deux opérations aboutissent en même
temps afin que les universitaires enfin
l'ensemble du personnel l'ensemble des
étudiants puissent bénéficier de moyens
de transport collectif
lorsque la gare sera déplacée alors
Nicole
brick monsieur le ministre vous nous
avez tenu des propos qui sont un peu à
l'identique de ce que vous avez déclaré
il y a peu de temps devant le Congrès de
l'Association des Maes d'Île-de-France
vous tenez des propos
apaisants la
complémentarité le respect des
compétences de la région ça c'est le
discours mais le texte
ne dit pas ça il dit à chaque
article la défiance qu'il a
envers la région Île-de-France et vous
venez encore d'en d'en apporter la
démonstration à l'appui de la défense de
votre
amendement vous accusez ni plus ni moins
le STIF c'est ce que vous avez dit j'ai
bien entendu votre déclaration de tout à
l'heure de manœuvre dilatoire alors je
vais vous dire que ce n'est pas
acceptable parce que moi je sais nous
euh avec mon collègue Yannick Baudin
nous connaissons les apres discussions
qu'a notre conseil général que nous
soutenons avec le STIF justement pour
organiser la délégation de compétences
et je peux vous dire que c'est long
c'est compliqué surtout quand par
imbrication des compétences de l'État
dans l'ancienne organisation du STIF il
y a des personnels qui sont finan
des personnels d'État qui été financé
par par le le
département et qu'il faut dénouer ce qui
avait été créé par des
années de gestion de l'État et je ne
vous permet pas de dire que le STIF fait
des une épreuve de retardement ce n'est
pas vrai il s'est mis à la tâche il a
envie de que cette délégation de
compétence se fasse moi i j'ai pas dit
qu'il fallait quatre autorités
organisatrices de proximité mais je
connais la réalité de ce que demandent
certains élus et même avec un délai au
au 1er juillet vous vous considérez que
vous avez fait un pas vers nous non nous
on demander on demande la suppression de
l'article parce que qu'est-ce qui se
passe si au 1er juillet on on y arrive
pas hein je le répète ça veut dire que
l'État prendra ses responsabilités pour
organiser le plateau comme si ça se
faisait comme ça alors qu'il y a des
bassins de vie des circulations et euh
la
complémentarité dans votre esprit c'est
bon ben tout le maillage finalement
c'est le Steve qui le fait et par
ailleurs vous ne vous ne prenez pas en
compte ni le SRIF vous l'avez encore
montré tout à
l'heure quand on a présenté des
amendements le prenant en considération
vous ne prenez pas en compte le plan de
mobilisation de la région mais vous
dites le Steve doit faire c'est à Lui
d'organiser le maillage et vous vous
prenez la
décision les décisions qui sont celles
d'une autorité excusez-moi de vous le
dire entièrement technocratique sans
tenir compte de la réalité des
territoire et des élus qui les
gouvernent bien donc je soumets cet
amendement 306 du gouvernement à
l'approbation notre assemblée qui est
pour
l'adopter qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est
adopté et l'article 29 et l'annexe B
ainsi amendé qui est pour l'adopté cet
article 29 qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté alors nous en
arrivons à un ultime amendement
puisqu'il concerne l'intitulé du projet
et c'est Dominique wanet qui nous le
présente non c'est Jean de cessard je
vois pas monsieur le
Président par cet amendement monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur monsieur le Président de
la Commission mes chers
collègues plutôt que d'appeler ce ce
projet de loi Grand Paris je vous
propose de l'appeler ainsi projet de loi
portant création d'un nouveau métro
automatique par cet amendement nous vous
proposons de donner un titre à ce projet
de loi plus en adéquation avec la
réalité du texte en effet l'essentiel du
projet de loi porte sur la création d'un
nouveau réseau de transport plus
précisément un métro
automatique dans son discours à la Cité
de l'architecture et du patrimoine en
avril 2009 le président de la République
voyait dans le projet Grand Paris un
projet de civilisation respectueux de
l'environnement un projet de lutte
contre les inégalités
sociales aujourd'hui ce projet de loi
apparaît comme le reste des réformes
sarkozis d'ailleurs un projet au Rabet
une publicité mensongère sans véritable
concertation avec les élus locaux sans
véritaable solution de financement et se
résume en un point la réalisation d'un
mitro automatique reliant des pôles
économiques entre eux qu'en est-il de la
réduction des inégalité sociale quand on
prévoit un mode de transport qui ne
relie pas les zones habitat travail
qu'en est-il du respect de
l'environnement lorsqu'on prévoit
d'ériger des bâtiments et un réseau de
transport sur l'une des dernières zones
agricoles proches de Paris plateau de
saclclet qu'en est-il de l'économie
solidaire lorsqu'on prévoit de
construire des gares commerciales à
vocation spéculative pour payer les
tuneliers qui vont creuser creuser
creuser creuser pendant 12 ans pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons nous vous
proposons donc de modifier le titre de
ce projet de loi afin d'être en accord
avec son contenu et je précise que ceux
qui ont lu qui disent queil s'agit de
d'un grand H je leur dis non c'est de zé
à coller un zéro pour l'environnement et
un zéro pour le
social merci Jean de cessard qu'en
pensez-vous monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre en général j'ai
beaucoup de sympathie pour Monsieur des
zessard parce que je trouve qu'il é gay
aimablement notre nos débats qui parfois
sont un peu longs mais là je je me
demande si Monsieur de zessard en
présentant son amendement a conscience
que dans ce qui vient dire au fond il
injurie les travaux de la commission et
comme je trouve que c'est vraiment
injurieux pour le temps que nous avons
passé à auditionner une cinquantaine de
responsables à aller sur place aussi
bien à Londres qu'à sa clé à discuter
pendant le 8h à la Commission pour
établir le texte et à avoir plus de 30
HE de débat je crois que ce n'est pas
raisonnable et par contre conséqu comme
ce qui est excessif n'est pas bon et
bien je serai défavorable à son
amendement monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président je
voudrais remercier le travail de la
commission spéciale et dire que par
ailleurs effectivement pour moi cet
amendement n'a aucun sens et que j'y
suis défavorable merci alors qui est
pour adopter
cette Philippe
dallierur ah bah oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je vais intervenir sur cet
amendement et ça m'évitera de le faire
sur le sur le vote final et je vous
redis monsieur le ministre que je
voterai votre texte malgré toutes les
réserves que j'ai pu exprimer parce que
je pense qu'effectivement votre projet
de
transport nous permettra d'atteindre le
but que vous vous fixez l'un des buts ou
le but essentiel que vous vous fixer
effectivement redonner du dynamisme
économique à cette région capitale et
elle en a besoin ceci étant dit ceci
étant dit moi je voterai bien
l'amendement de Monsieur le cessar et je
vous l'ai déjà dit d'ailleurs je trouve
qu'effectivement et ça n'est franchement
monsieur le rapporteur pas injurier les
travaux de la commission en tous les
cass non non en tous les
cas non non non non non absolument pas
absolument pas en tous les cas tous les
cas alors là franchement
monsieur le rapporteur je moi je veux
simplement expliquer mon point de vue et
d'ailleurs monsieur le rapporteur à un
moment donné au début de nos travaux si
la mémoire ne me fait pas défaut et je
pense qu'elle ne me fait pas défaut la
question a été posé de savoir s'il
fallait changer le le titre de ce projet
parce qu'effectivement considérer qu'il
est tout le Grand Paris à lui-même
écoutez moi je ne peux pas partager ce
point de vue et j'ai essayé de vous le
démontrer tout au cours des débats et je
n'ai pas changé d'avis après avoir
entendu les réponses du ministre le
Grand Paris c'est effectivement voir
comment nous assurons la cohésion
urbaine et sociale de l'ensemble et si
effectivement nous avons bien un réseau
de transport nous aurons bien des des
contrats de développement territorial
nous nous avons aussi une crainte et
nous l'avons exprimé moi je l'ai exprimé
d'un manque de cohérence de l'ensemble
j'ai des interrogations sur le partage
de la richesse fiscale qui sera
effectivement généré grâce au projet de
métro automatique et de cela je suis
satisfait mais toutes ces questions là
elles se posent sur le logement on a
pris en compte l'objectif de 70000
logements par an à atteindre en
redonnant au préfet de région les
pouvoirs écoutez est-ce qu'on atteindra
l'objectif est-ce que la mixité sociale
sera assurée moi je n'ai pas de garantie
là-dessus je l'espère mais je n'ai pas
de garantie et pourtant pour moi faire
le Grand Paris c'est bien effectivement
traiter tous ces problèmes et tr était
le problème de la gouvernance que nous
n'avons pas abordé autrement qu'au
travers de la gouvernance de la GP sur
laquelle il y a eu quelques avancées
mais encore beaucoup d'interrogations
mais sur la gouvernance des
collectivités locales nous n'avons pas
avancé du tout peut-être que nous
avancerons à l'avenir et effectivement à
ce moment-là lorsque nous aurons traité
de l'ensemble de ces problèmes
pourra-t-on parler de la concrétisation
de ce Grand Paris que chacun ici et
c'est peut-être ce qui nous rassemble
j'ai quand même le sentiment que de la
droite à la gauche on on cherche tous à
atteindre le même objectif la question
c'est effectivement de savoir comment on
y parvient et au bénéfice de qui et
c'est là effectivement où il y a
peut-être des des divergences alors
changer le titre de ce projet de loi moi
ça ne me choque pas et je ne pense
franchement monsieur le rapporteur ça
n'est absolument pas vous faire un jure
ni à vous ni au travail de la commission
et sur ces ces bans nous sommes nombreux
à avoir participé aux travaux de cette
commission alors pour
terminer peut-être citer brcht qui
disait si ma mémoire est bonne la la
provocation est une manière de remettre
la réalité sur ses pieds alors parfois
qu'on est peut-être un peu trop dans
l'excès et c'est peut-être parfois mon
cas mais si je veux être provocateur
c'est effectivement pour provoquer cette
prise de conscience collective que dans
cet espace du Grand Paris ça ne peut pas
continuer ainsi sinon la rupture la
fracture sociale que nous constatons
entre les territoires elle ne se
résorbera pas et c'est pourtant moi ce
qui me tient à cœur parce que c'est
l'avenir de la République qui en dépend
alors ensuite Yannick Budin Yve poo du
borgau et Nicole borveau
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
rapporteur cet amendement de présenté
par Monsieur de cessar a une qualité
quand même
essentielle c'est que il nous ramène je
dirais à la vérité
vraie c'est-à-dire à la perception en
tout état de cause qui est faite par la
plupart des Franciliens de ce qui a été
présenté comme le projet du 21e siècle
du Grand
Paris est-ce que ça concerne seulement
toute la région d'Île de France à
l'évidence non je suis d'un département
la cénémarne où franchement cette
histoire nous échappe
complètement et pour beaucoup de
frantiliens c'est exactement de même
nature on pouvait s'attendre à ce que le
Grand Paris soit quelquun projet pour
l'île de France à savoir qu'on allait
s'attaquer au véritable problème qui
font la spécificité malheureusement la
spécificité aussi de notre région
c'est-à-dire en
particulier la fracture très grande qui
existe sur le plan social entre ceux qui
gagnent les salaires les plus élevés qui
ont les plus grands
revenu et ceux qui en même temps sont
dans la plus grande souffrance nous
avons toutes ces populations là dans
notre région et on pouvait imaginer que
le projet ce qui porterait le projet
c'était ce que nous chercherions et ce
que nous trouverions en matière d'emploi
en matière d'éducation de formation en
matière de
logement en fin de compte il est tout à
fait exact que la perception qu'on en a
correspond bien à la réalité surtout
lorsqu'on est à plus de 50 km de Paris
qu' s'agit tout simplement de la
création d'un nouveau métro
automatique ce qui fait que je suis prêt
à soutenir cet amendement dans cet
esprit-là encore que je ferai un petit
reproche à mon ami de cessard en lui
disant qu'il n'a quand même peut-être
pas été tout à fait complet et près de
la réalité et moi je proposerai un
sous-amendement monsieur le ministre ça
serait que l'on dise et l'on intitule
votre projet de loi projet de loi pant
création d'un nouveau métro automatique
et d'une silicone
Vall bien on
continue Bor ensuite Nicole Bor et
Dominique juste remarir mon collèg c'est
vra j'ai toujours apprécié rapport et ça
m'a beaucoup inspiré dans la réflexion
que j'ai actuellement surffire du Grand
Paris je comprends pas
si j'ai bien compris ce débat qu'on a
depuis tout depuis le début de cette du
travail la commission spéciale et depuis
le travail en science qu'on a avec
collègues de gauche on voit très bien
qu'il y a deux choses qu' a deux
conceptions de ce Grand Paris vous avez
nos amis de la gauche communist Parti
socialiste et aut qui nous entraînent
qui veulent nous entraîner pour nous
dire ce n'est pas un projet national
européen c'est un projet régional et
vous prenez la place de la région nous
qu'est-ce que c'est
nous vous expliquons que cette affaire
n'est pas du tout un projet régional
c'est un projet national et européen la
façon par exemple dont les deux
normandis se sont intéressés à ce projet
pour devenir la face maritime du Grand
Paris prouve qu'ils ont compris prouve
que nos collègues de ces deux régions de
droite comme de gauche ont compris que
ce projet n'était pas un projet régional
mais un projet national ce qui explique
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'amendements que
j'ai fait que je défendrai tout à
l'heure mais c'est ça la différence et
c'est ça et quand monsieur des cessar
demande que ça devienne être automatique
et bien on retrouve le même débat où nos
amis de gauche et des verts et des
communistes V nous ramener en disant ce
n'est pas un grand projet non c'est un
projet régional et bien non non c'est un
projet national et je regrette monsieur
daer ce piage làdessus alors là où je
rejoin monsieur daer il a tout à fait
raison ce Grand Paris là où je vous
rejoins le texte du Grand Paris point
non moi je suis pas pour le point je
suis le Grand Paris virgule parce que ce
texte c'est le texte de Grand Paris qui
annonce d'autres et c'est là où je vous
rejoins mais je vous ne rejoins pas en
disant je soutiens nos amis de gauche ou
des ver ou je rejos nos amis de gauche
et des veres pour dire que ce projet est
un projet régional voilà c'est un projet
national si nous avons pris le risque
que ça devienne d'ailleurs je le dirai
je tout à l'heure quand il plusieurs
interventions je me disais mais attendez
chaque président de la République a eu
ses grands travaux giscar a eu le TGV et
Milie d'orsé c'est François mitan qui
les a inauguré mais c'est quand même lui
qui les a lancé François miteran a eu
ses grands travaux lui aussi alors il a
pu les inaugurer parce qui restait 14
ans le président jacquesira qui ses
grands travaux avec le kbranli et bien
le président Sarkozi par le B de Chisson
blanc a ses grands travaux et c'est la
première fois qu'on a un président de la
République qui est une région et ces
grands travaux c'est le Grand Paris
voilà bien allez Nicole BO Nicole
boci merci monsieur le Président euh
écoutez nous nous n'allons pas soutenir
le l'amendement de notre collègue euh de
modification du
titre sans doute quand il s'il veut dire
que ce projet ne correspond pas aux
attentes et aux besoins de
l'Île-de-France a-t-il raison mais ceci
dit ce projet est beaucoup plus qu'un
projet de métro automatique c'est un
projet on peut dire que c'est
effectivement un projet un grand projet
libéral de restructuration de la région
Île-de-France avec évidemment sbassement
des un intérêt sans doute national mais
que nous ne partageons absolument pas je
crois qu'au contraire tout le tout le la
discussion l'a montré d'ailleurs avec
les pouvoirs qui sont donnés à la
Société du Grand Paris passant outre
d'ailleurs la dém ocratie locale comme
et d'ailleurs nationale aussi comme nous
l'avons essayé de le montrer toute au
long de la discussion il donne des
pouvoirs exorbitants à l'état pour
restructurer la région avec des pouvoirs
d'aménagement du territoire de donc de
structuration complète tant du point de
vue de l'économie avec la création de
pôle économique sans doute d'ailleurs au
détriment de la diversité économique de
la région Île-de-France des projets
structurant du point de vue du logement
du point de vue de l'habitat et du point
de vue des population encore une fois je
crois que ce projet va effectivement
vise le long terme je ne sais pas s'il
aboutira le problème de ce projet c'est
que à l'heure actuelle il y a quand même
des sacré questions de financement qui
ne sont pas réglé et là ça laisse sans
doute des discussions à venir que je
sais pas si le président de la
République mènera à bout ce projet
grandiose mais en tout cas j'espère que
non
mais ce qui est certain c'est que la la
visée que vous avez avec ce projet c'est
sans doute de pour de longues années
restructurer complètement la région
Île-de-France repousser les populations
les plus modestes encore plus loin
toujours plus loin et de ce point de vue
effectivement il peut se rapprocher
d'autres projets en France on a connu
Osmane on connaîtra le projet du du
Grand Paris de projets aussi dans
d'autres pays européen que vous ventez à
qui mieux mieux comme le Grand Londres
ou ou autres du même genre dont on peut
voir d'ailleurs le résultat à savoir des
une spéculation effrainée des
populations chassées de plus en plus
loin la casse de la
diversité économique locale et au profit
de quoi de grands groupes financ qui
n'attendent que ça bien entendu
c'est-à-dire une manne venant de la part
de l'État pour pouvoir conquérir des
marchés dans la région donc je crois
qu'il serait effectivement ne serait pas
conforme à la réalité de ce projet de
croire qu'il s'agit simplement de la
création d'un métro
automatique merci et pour terminer
Dominique
wanet c'est bon alors je
soumets
Jean de cessard vous avez la
parole non non mais elle ne prend
pas non non
allez-y non non non
non non non je préside
ok bon d'abord je voulais dire à
monsieur le rapporteur qui avait jusqu'à
maintenant mené les débat de façon
intéressante
respectueuse que il s'agit une heure de
la fin de se laisser aller et quand il
parle
que sous prétexte qu'on est pas d'accord
avec un projet politique qu'on fait
injure à la commission qui a beaucoup
travaillé je signale ici que le Sénat à
certain moment a beaucoup travaillé sur
des projets comme le CPE le contrat
première embauche et puis qu'ensuite on
s'aperçoit au bout de 15 jours 3
semaines de discussion sur le CPE il est
voté et après le gouvernement vient qu'
jour après nous demander de le retirer
alors ça si c'est pas faire un jure au
Parlement si c'est pas faire un jure à
la commission qui a travaillé sur le
dossier c'est également la même chose
sur le droit opposable au logement nous
avons une loi logement il y a eu des
amendements qui a demandé qui ont
demandé le droit opposable logement ça
été refusé il y a une occupation du
canal Saint-Martin des tentes qui se
mettent en place et monsieur borlot
vient nous proposer le droitosable au
logement donc attention attention
lorsqu'on dit qu'on n pas d'accord
politiquement et qu'on dit alors là
c'est pas respectueux du travail qui a
été fait vous avez certainement
auditionné vous avez certainement fait
un excellent travail mais c'est pas pour
autant que nous sommes d'accord et là je
vais faire une surprise monsieur prodzo
du Borgo je ne suis pas opposé même en
tant qu'écologiste qu'il y ait des
grandes
réalisations je n'ai pas dit des grands
travaux pour rien j'ai dit des grandes
réalisations et là en l'occurrence ce
n'est pas une grande réal tion on n'a
pas tenu compte des avis des 10
architectes on fait un métro souterrain
ça rappelle le 19e siècle au 19e siècle
c'était effectivement d'actualité
moderne de faire les métros qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire aujourd'hui des
transports euh on on on dit souvent que
que les écologistes c'est les grottes le
retour à la grotte et à la bougie là
c'est le retour au tunnel et au Bogy
hein et donc ça fait si il n'est pas
vrai que le le transport collectif du
21e siècle est un tunnel de 130 km ce
n'est pas vrai ce n'est pas ma
conception même en tant qu'écologiste il
est évident que le déplacement agréable
c'est le déplacement de
surface et c'est à croire qu'il ça
manqué de cafétéria créatrice que
peut-être que vous n'êtes pas allé assez
avec discuter avec les uns et les autres
pour envisager un projet novateur
créateur comment peut-on penser que le
Grand Paris c'est un tunnel de 130 km
comment peut-on penser que les gens vont
avoir plaisir à s'engouffrer dans un
tunnel pour faire 130 km dans le noir
dans le tunnel mais c'est pas vrai ce
n'est pas comment on peut le penser
ensuite sur comment peut-on ne pas
croire que ces gares commerciales qui
vont servir à payer les tunneliers ne
seront pas des opérations de spéculation
comment ne pas croire que le prix du
terrain va coûter cher et qu'il n'y aura
plus d'activité agricole donc donc
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez le
droit de croire à ce projet mais
laissez-nous quand même penser que pour
nous il n'est pas faisable il n'est pas
crédible alors je soumets cet amendement
236 de Jean de cessar avec deux avis
défavorables de la Commission et du
gouvernement à votre approbation qui est
pour adopter cet
amendement qui est
contre il n'est pas
adopté je vais mettre au vo l'ensemble
du projet de loi il a-t-il des demandes
d'explication de V alors madame
assass monsieur café madame VO
Mad monsieur
Bor et Monsieur
B et oui oui mais je vous avais déjà
inscrit voilà et le rapporur et le
rappte et puis le rapporteur pour
terminer allez Françoise labor vous
commencez monsieur le président monsieur
le secrétaire d'État mes chers collègues
le Grand Paris entendu comme projet qui
doit permettre un développement
économique mieux organisé et stratégique
de la région Paris
aurait à n'en pas douter un effet
d'entraînement bénéfique pour tout le
reste du pays aussi l'idée d'un Grand
Paris est une belle excellente idée tout
le monde ici sur ces bans convient élu
de gauche comme de droite élu de
l'île-de-fance comme de la province et
pourtant nous serons nombreux sur ces
bans à ne pas apporter nos voix à ce
projet de loi la région parisienne
enregistre une croissance de 2 % quand
les autres grandes capitales sont à 4 %
dans un monde de plus en plus ouvert où
la concurrence est vive il est urgent de
donner à Paris et à sa périphérie les
moyens de conserver une attractivité qui
les maintiennent au tout premier rang
celui des régions les plus dynamiques de
la planète pour ce faire le gouvernement
a fait le choix avec ce projet de loi de
s'en remettre à la création d'un
établissement public à caractère
industriel et commercial dénommé Société
du Grand Paris chargé de développer un
réseau de transport inérêt national et
de favoriser le développement économique
et urbain autour desgards de ce réseau
mais pour lancer ce grand chantier du
Grand Paris qui va durer de très
nombreuses années le gouvernement
utilise une fois encore la procédure
accélérée au détriment de la qualité du
débat parlementaire nous aurions
souhaité disposer du délai nécessaire à
une réflexion approfondie sur les enjeux
stratégiques et économiques portés par
ce texte d'intérêt national quant aux
consultations des principaux acteurs
concernés qui auraient dû précéder
l'élaboration d'un tel texte elles ont
été réduites au service minimum les élus
franciliens n'ont pas cessé de vous le
répéter ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
les collectivités locales n'ont eu que
quelques semaines pour donner leur avis
sur un texte qui engage leur territoire
pour plusieurs décennies semblant de
dialogue avec les collectivités
d'Île-de-France pour préparer le texte
et donc fort logiquement cela se traduit
par une mise à l'écart des collectivités
dont la prise en charge du Grand Paris
la place prépondérante accordé à l'État
au sein du conseil de surveillance de la
Société du Grand Paris tient
soigneusement à distance les élus
franciliens alors que des pans entiers
de leur territoire vont être réaménagés
ils seront dépossédés d'un grand nombre
de leurs prérogatives en matière
d'urbanisme et de transport avec un tel
schéma de gouvernance c'est
nécessairement une recentralisation qui
en découlera drôle de conception de
l'organisation décentralisée de la
République qui est pourtant inscrite
dans la Constitution ce nouvel équipe
épique pardon va cumuler de façon
autoritaire à la fois les compétences de
maître d'ouvrage celle d'aménageur et
celle d'opérateurs fonciers quand dans
le même temps il faut bien rappeler que
l'histoire de l'aménagement de
l'île-de-fance est marqué par un
désengagement progressif de l'État
pourtant ce sont bien les responsables
locaux qui ont clairement identifié les
priorités en se fondant sur les attentes
des usagers la rénovation des lignes du
RER le désengargement de le
désengorgement de la ligne 13 le
prolongement de la ligneol la création
de la rocade arc-enciel express et je
pourrais en citer d'autres il serait
également important d'intégrer d'autres
dimension de l'action publique pour
donner davantage de cohérence au Grand
Paris et même en faisant abstraction de
la question de la gouvernance comment
pourra-t-on répondre avec ce texte à la
question la plus fondamentale qui est
répondre au défis de la fracture sociale
au sein de ce territoire comment
prétendre donner de l'attractivité à une
région sans anticiper davantage les
questions d'emploi de logement et
d'environnement ce texte manque
cruellement de souffle démocratique mais
également d'ambition pour la population
francilienne c'est un texte bien en
desessà de nos espérances un texte qui
réduit la belle idée du Grand Paris à sa
seule dimension
technocratique c'est pourquoi les
parlementaire que nous sommes ne devrait
pas se faire complice de son adoption
vous l'aurez compris mes chers collègues
aucun des sénateurs radicaux de gauche
ne votera ce projet de loi même après
les modifications apportées par notre
Haute Assemblée il en dira de même pour
la très grande majorité des sénateurs de
mon groupe je vous remercie Françoise
labordien Assassi
oui merci monsieur le Président euh ma
collègue Nicole borveau a déjà dit un
certain nombre de choses de fond donc je
vais essayer de synthétiser cette
explication de vote des élus de mon
groupe qui
s'oppose à à à ce texte et je vais je
voudrais simplement pour donc expliquer
ce vote revenir sur quelques
points la première chose je pense qu'il
est nécessaire de la rappeler euh il
nous l' avons dit dans nos interventions
générales mais je pense qu'il faut le
redire avec force
euh que le le le vote des
Franciliens aux élections régionales euh
avait a plus exactement des avoués euh
votre politique et donc s'agissant de la
région
Île-de-France à désavoué votre projet du
du du Grand Paris et donc à l'évidence
et malheureusement les longues heures de
débat que nous avons eu soit à la
commission spéciale qui furent très
intéressants soit dans les myes qui le
furent tout autant mais à l'évidence
donc vous n'en avait que faire
et et c'est vrai que cette attitude
ignore purement et simplement euh ce
vote et les représentants du peuple élus
donc démocratiquement la preuve avec Arc
Express projet qui pourtant répond à à
de
véritables besoins des besoins plus
concertés avec les populations et je
pense que ce choix illustre
particulièrement euh votre refus
d'honorer les contrats de plan et ça
nous ne pouvons l'accepter par ailleurs
euh nous sommes et nous restons opposés
si mes collègues socialistes le
permettent dans le silence
la preuve c'est qu'il n'écoute même pas
voilà par ailleurs nous sommes et nous
restons fortement opposés au fait que
des structures technocratiques comme la
p mais aussi comme l'établissement
public de
saclet se voit confier des compétences
politiques ce qui revient à dévitaliser
les collectivités territoriales et nous
l'avons rappelé à maintre reprise ceci
est est conforme à la réforme des
collectivités territoriales nous pensons
également que la double boucle ne
répondra pas aux besoins immédiats des
11 millions de francyens euh
particulièrement quand il euh font
savoir la nécessité d'améliorer les
transports ce que proposé pourtant le
plan de mobilisation de la région
Île-de-France et j'aurais affirme ici
que ce qu'il faut pour répondre à ses
besoins c'est peut-être d'un grand H8
mais c'est surtout un maillage cohérent
avec la création de nouveaux segments au
sein du réseau qui existe alors
s'agissant du financement il me semble
enfin il nous semble qu'en la matière
votre projet est relativement
àéatoatoire en effet donc outre une
dotation en capital de 4 milliards son
son financement reposera principalement
sur un recours à l'emprunt dont le
rembourser le remboursement se fera via
la valorisation des terrains c'est un
Paris sur un développement hypothétique
qu'un projet de loi ne peut prévoir et
même pas Nicolas Sarkozi alors on nous a
parlé de l'air d'après Kyoto et
cetera mais j'oseraai dire pour
que le financement attendu cela suppos
supposerait de la croissance et du
développement urbain autour des gares et
dans l'interstice entre le réseau du
Grand 8 et le cœur de la métropole et
qui peut dire aujourd'hui ce qu'il en
sera réellement qui peut aujourd'hui euh
qui peut dire aujourd'hui que l'État
l'état tiendra ses promesses alors même
que l'on nous assène à longueur de
journée que celui-ci est en déficit
voilà quant à la logique de cluster
soutendu par le Tex celle-ci nous semble
inefficace puisque elle aboutit à une
mise en concurrence des territoires par
leur spécialisation votre texte porte le
projet d'une société que nous dénonçons
la société de la rentabilité de la
compétitivité de la concurrence dont les
écueils sont pourtant connus depuis la
crise que nous traversons à l'inverse
nous réaffirmons qu'une région solidaire
passe nécessairement par une
mutualisation des moyens et des et des
ressources comme il me reste peu de
temps je vais conclure euh il me semble
que j'aurais voulu encore illustrer mon
propos par les conclusions d'un rapport
dont vous avez sans doute entendu parler
monsieur le secrétaire d'État le rapport
Le Fèvre qui a été émis en février 2009
pour l'institut CDC et qui conditionnait
la réussite de tout projet métropolitain
un certain nombre
d'impératifs parmi lequel la nécessité
que ce soit un projet global et non la
réalisation d'un simple métro classe à
faire et visiblement vous vous éloignez
de ces impératifs pourtant retenus dans
ce contenu dans ce raort enfin pour
sortir et j'en finis monsieur le
Président de cet impasse puisque vous ne
pourrez mettre en œuvre à un projet pour
l'Île-de-France contre ses élus et
contre sa population il me semble que
vous devriez revoir la copie et non
passer en force avec ce texte dont les
débats n'ont pas permis d'infléchir la
logique et j'en finirai avec deux pistes
euh que nous considérons comme première
la première serait
euh premièrement pardon serait de
remettre tous les acteurs politiques
autour de la table la région les
collectivités locales et l'État et la
deuxième piste serait de réimpulser
l'Atelier international d'architecture
dont le travail avait suscité
l'enthousiasme partagé entre les élus et
les citoyens pour affiner un projet
commun en pointintant l'exigence de
penser ensemble les quatre domaines
d'action publique prioritaire que sont
le logements les transports l'emploi et
les équipements merci iian assassie
Jean-Pierre
café merci Monsieur le le Président je
voudrais commencer par dire à monsieur
le rapporteur que ce n'est pas faire un
jure à la commission spéciale et encore
moins à sa
personne que d'affirmer ce soir que nous
ne voterons pas ce texte nous avons été
d'ailleurs un certain nombre dans mon
groupe à reconnaître la qualité des
travaux qui ont été menés par cette
commission mais enfin c'est la
démocratie de ne pas être convaincu par
le texte qui en ressort car après tout
il y a bien une majorité une minorité
cette majorité cette minorité se
retrouve dans la commission spéciale
donc ce que je vais dire n'est pas une
injure au rapporteur mais simplement si
vous voulez le constat que nous tirons
de ce débat tant à l'Assemblée nationale
que dans cet hémicycle et pour nous si
vous voulez bon ce que nous tirons en
fait de de ce débat c'est que véritable
ement c'est une occasion manquée cette
affaire de Grand Paris d'abord monsieur
le secrétaire d'État le Grand Paris ça
n'appartient à personne vous n'êtes pas
vous n'en êtes pas l'initiateur ou
l'inventeur nous non plus d'ailleurs d'
un processus qui a commencé il y a quand
même quelques années et dont personne si
vous voulez ne veut revendiquer ici la
paternité parce que franchement c'est
pas ça le sujet et ça n'a pas d'intérêt
mais enfin je voudrais dire que le Grand
Paris n'a pas commencé avec ce projet de
loi et il est vrai que le Grand Paris
c'est c'était une idée au départ qui
était tout à fait passionnante et dont
les travaux qui ont été menés par les 10
équipe d'architectes étit extrêmement
prometteuse et finalement à couche d'un
texte qui je le répète est une occasion
manquée et comme bon je n'ai que que 5
minutes je développerai trois occasions
manquées la première occasion manquée
c'est celle de la conviction monsieur le
secrétaire d'État vous ne nous avez pas
convaincu
vous nous avez pas convaincu sur la
stratégie économique que vous avez suivi
d'ailleurs vous ne l'avez pas cherché
comme le fait remarquer très justement
ma collègue Nicole brick vous nous avez
pas convaincu en affirmant qu'il
suffisait pour restaurer la
compétitivité de l'île-de-fance de
relier 8 ne9 pôles de développement
entre eux par 140 km de métro
automatique souterrain vous nous avez
pas convaincu non plus en abandonnant un
certain nombre de sujets fondamentaux
pour le dév devement de l'île de France
comme le logement par exemple monsieur
le secrétaire d'État je ne prendrais
qu'un exemple vous avez annoncé by à
orby 1 million d'emplois supplémentaire
grâce à votre projet de
loi chacun a fait le calcul et vous le
savez parfaitement monsieur le
secrétaire d'État vous autant que nous 1
million d'emplois supplémentaires ça
nécessiterait auamo ou en tout cas
environ 100000 logements par an
supplémentaire le texte de loi se
contente des 70000 et ne donne aucun
moyen pour y pour y parvenir je passe
également parce que je vois que les
minutes s'écoulent sur tout ce qu'on dit
un certain nombre d'entre nous je pense
notamment en fait à Philippe Dalier sur
les problèmes récurrents que nous avons
en île- de-fance celle de l'égalité
territoriale des disparités
territoriales de la béréquation fiscale
qui sont totalement absents donc
monsieur le secrétaire d'État non sur le
fond vous ne nous avez pas convaincu et
j'ai cru remarquer d'ailleurs un certain
nombre d'occasion dans ce débat ici que
vous n'avez pas convaincu également la
totalité de votre majorité et d'ailleurs
ça n'est pas moi qui parle de
déclaration de guerre c'est le
rapporteur du texte à l'Assemblée
nationale Ival barilo qui s'exprime dans
20 minutes il y a il y a quelques jours
en disant le texte tel qui ressort du
Sénat est une déclaration de guerre aux
collectivités territoriales et notamment
à la région 2ième occasion manquée et
j'accélère parce que encore une fois le
temps passe c'est celle des des
engagements monsieur le secrétaire
d'État que vous le vouliez ou non ce
projet n'est pas financé vous le savez
parfaitement vous avez essayé je rejoint
la conviction sur laquelle vous avez
échoué vous avez tenté de nous faire
croire que ce projet serait autofinancé
par les plusvalu foncière vous savez
très bien que ce n'est pas vrai et non
seulement ce n'est pas vrai mais en plus
par une décision totalement
incompréhensible vous avez renoncé à une
partie à une partie de la plusvalue
foncière en euh restraignant le champ
sur lequel elle pouvait être perçue
enfin et j'en terminerai par là la
troisième occasion manquée c'est sans
doute la plus grave monsieur le
secrétaire d'État c'est celle d'un
partenariat que vous auriez pu nouer
avec les collectivités territoriales
c'est là à mon avis que vous faites la
principale erreur vous nous avez dit que
toutes les compétences des collectivités
étaient respecé à la lettre je crois que
nous avons fait la démonstration que ça
n'était pas vrai pour ne prendre qu'un
exemple
pour ne prendre qu'un exemple le STIF
j'ai posé nous avons posé des questions
extrêmement précises sur le respect des
articles 10 11 14 15 du décret de 2015
qui porte décentralisation sur STIF nous
n'avons pas la réponse et vous savez
très bien que non seulement vous ne le
respectez pas mais vous les violz alors
monsieur le secrétaire d'État et je
conclus vous pouvez toujours vous
rassurer en disant que les discussions
bilatérales que vous mener avec un
certain nombre d'élus avec un certain
nombre de maires vont plutôt dans le bon
sens et d'une certaine manière quand je
dis que vous ne respectez pas les
collectivités territorial c'est
peut-être un peu plus grave que ça
c'est-à-dire que vous cherchez à les
diviser vous cherchez à renier des
compétences de la région et d'un certain
nombre de communes et en même temps vous
discutez de manière totalement
bilatérale avec un certain nombre de
maires monsieur le secrétaire d'État ce
que je crois c'est que cette discussions
que vous menez même si vous si vous en
et satisfaction sont probablement des
victoires à la pyus et puisqu'il faut
que je termine et j'ai dépassé mon temps
n'oubliez jamais monsieur le secrétaire
d'État comment a fini
pyus merci Dominique
voanet monsieur le Président je ne vais
pas promettre d'être brève parce qu'on
sait comment ça se termine mais nous
sommes invités à nous prononcer sur un
projet de loi qui afficher l'ambition de
dessiner la région île-de-fance de
demain de faire entrer Paris dans le 21e
siècle ce devait être un projet global
pour la région capitale le projet de
tous les Franciliens voire de tous les
Français il se voulait d'intérêt
national il devait réunir différents
acteurs des architectes des urbanistes
des collectivités territoriales des
habitants permettre à la fois à Paris de
s'inscrire d'égal à égal avec Londres ou
shanghï dans la compétition
internationale et à cliché sous bois de
retrouver un peu d'espoir au final vous
nous l'avez montré en séance monsieur le
secrétaire d'État ce projet n'est pas le
fruit d'un travail commun mais
l'expression de la volonté d'un homme
presque seul contre tous ce n'est
pourtant pas l'opposition qui a déploré
avec le plus de vééence dans cet
hémicycle mais bien des membres de votre
propre majorité le projet du Grand Paris
sera élaboré et enrichi collectivement
où il ne sera pas vous avez choisi de
mener seul ce projet restant sourd aux
appels des architectes qui pointent ses
incohérences vous avez travaillé pendant
2 ans sur ce texte 2 ans mais c'est un
luxe dans un pays où un préfet par
exemple dispose parfois d'à peine plus
d'un an pour faire ses preuves ça a été
le cas dans mon département de scè
saain-denis après 15 mois malgré la
difficulté de la tâche il a été remplacé
vous avez ignoré le travail de la région
Île-de-France matérialisé dans le sdriff
dans un mouvement recentralisateur
inédit vous avez mis en sommeil la CNDP
vous n'avez eu de cesse d'inventer des
procédures dérogatoires au droit commun
de la concertation vous avez manifesté à
chaque instant une inexplicable défiance
dans la sagesse et le courage des élus
locaux le résultat de ce travail
solitaire est sans appel le Grand Paris
se résume à un projet de métro
automatique reliant des aéroports à de
futurs pôles de développement sans avoir
levé les incertitudes sur son trajet
nous n'avons toujours pas de plan précis
sur son financement sur son utilité sans
tenir compte des risques en matière
d'étalement urbain ou en matière de
disparition de terre arable vous
renoncez à répondre aux véritables
attentes des habitants ils le disent
avec force ils ont besoin de logement de
transport qui puissent les amener plus
rapidement sur leur lieu de travail ils
aspirent aussi à un développement plus
harmonieux à une ville moins
inégalitaire et moins violente mais
c'est l'inverse que nous leur proposons
avec ce projet vous avez fait le Paris
de constituer des poches de richesse
autour des 40 gares de ce super métro
grâce à la spéculation foncière que vous
appelez de vos vœux pour essayer de
financer les coûts colossaux de
fonctionnement de ce projet où sont les
moyens concrets nouveaux dont nous
aurions besoin pour créer les logements
don on affirme pourtant qu'on veut les
construire pour résorber l'habitat
insalubre pour traiter la question
lancinante du manque d'hébergement
d'urgence pour enrayer la spirale de la
violence dans nos quartiers sur fond de
trafic d'armes ou de drogue pour
restaurer la tranquillité publique dans
les transport Jean de cessard ne vous a
pas insulté monsieur le rapporteur en
suggérant que le texte est loin bien
loin des ambitions affichées et des
rêves et des espoirs nés de cet
affichage et d'ailleurs quand on regarde
les questions que vous avez posé
vous-même à chaque audition dans la
phase de travail de la commission
spéciale on voit bien que beaucoup
d'entre elles n'ont pas à cette heure
trouvé de réponse et vous ne pouvez pas
l'ignorer alors la question est
aujourd'hui de savoir si nous sommes en
mesure de tirer les leçons de de ces
expérience pour penser la ville de
demain ou si nous allons au contraire
nous enferrer dans l'erreur il est
malheureusement à craindre que
l'autosatisfaction et la méthode Coué
tiennent lieu de méthode pour la facee
qui vient
merci Dominique wanet Catherine
Tasca merci monsieur le président
monsieur le secrétaire d'État mes chers
collègues nous arrivons au terme de ce
débat avec un double sentiment une
double déception devrais-je dire
premièrement pour nous au groupe
socialiste débat signifie échange
d'arguments or tout au long de l'examen
de ce texte nos collègues de la majorité
ont été étrangement silencieux alors que
plusieurs d'entre eux sont très
directement concernés le territoire
qu'il représente ici étant fortement
impacté par ce projet de loi ils avaient
d'ailleurs été bien plus participants au
débat en commission spéciale leur
consentement silencieux dans notre
hémicycle ne contribue pas à valoriser
le travail parlementaire et cela ne
laisse pas de nous inquiéter
deuxièmement nous avons le S
en effet comme l'a dit mon collègue café
d'un rendez-vous manqué nous avons assez
largement adhéré aux objectifs de ce
projet il aurait pu être l'occasion de
renforcer la
décentralisation voire d'innover en
matière de démocratie moderne et
efficace et de mettre en œuvre un
partenariat équilibré entre l'État les
collectivités territorial et les acteurs
de la vie scientifique par défiance à
l'égard des collectivités locales que
vous renvoyez à un statut de mineur par
regain
d'autoritarisme contredisant la
recherche affiché
d'efficacité vous vous êtes arrêté sur
un schéma qui ne donnera assurément pas
les meilleurs chance de réussite à ce
projet ce projet est certes d'intérêt
national mais cela n'impliquit pas
nécessairement de sacrifier la
décentralisation et là est notre grand
Diver avec vous c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre groupe votera contre ce
projet de loi merci Catherine tas alors
le temps qui nous était
imparti et bien est pratiquement terminé
puisque nous devions terminer pour
minuit je vous consulte mais je suis
convaincu que nous déciderons tous
ensemble de prolonger de quelques
minutes pour terminer le texte il y a
pas de désaccord
allez Borgo vous avez la
parole je crois monsieur le Président
contenu de l'heure que j'ai déjà dit
beaucoup de choses j'allais les
reprendre les synthétiser mais peut-être
pour faire gagner du temps tout est déjà
escrit dans ce que j'ai dit donc je
préfère que aille beaucoup plus vite
toujours d'accord avec votre présidence
merci
bien pour vous av annoncer quand même
que mon groupe en grande majorité pour
ce texte là voilà je vous compris je dis
pour mes amis qui s'est interrogé
peut-être allez la
oui alors en deux mots ce que je
voudrais dire au nom du du groupe UMP
d'abord que effectivement il s'agit d'un
projet d'envergure nationale et une
volonté de faire en sorte de replacer
notre région capitale dans la
compétition mondiale et ça je crois que
c'est dommage queon ne l'ai pas senti
dans les débats dans la mesure où tous
nos collègues ont cherché à ramener les
choses à un niveau beaucoup plus plus
modeste certes important mais en
oubliant cet objectif qui est important
et je pense que ceux qui se passeront à
côté le regretteront plus tard moi ce
que je voudrais puisque on on on va très
vite remercier le rapporteur pour la
qualité du travail qu'il a mené et je
crois
qu'effectivement je l'applaudis
aussi qui a fait en sorte que ce projet
de loi soit soit revu en profondeur sur
un certain nombre de sujets qui devaient
l'être je pense au problème du logement
je pense au problème du Haut Débit je
pense à une vision qui au-delà
de la double boucle inclu un certain
nombre de transports avec notamment la
Normandie avec un certain nombre de
réalisations qui
appartiendront au à la SNCF je pense
aussi à tout le travail qui a été mené
sur le plateau de
saclé et je le remercie une fois de plus
sur la sanctuirisation des 2300 hactares
et puis je crois aussi que chacun au
sein de la Commission a apporté une
pierre à l'édifice je remercie Christian
Cambon concernant la priorité nécessaire
sur les transports existants sur lequel
je partage complètement son sentiment et
sur lequel nous avons nous autres
habitants des lointaines Barlieu
l'impression d'être totalement délaissé
oublié par le STIF et donc je crois que
nous avons les uns et les autres
travaillé apporter notre pierre à
l'édifice et par conséquent nous avons
aujourd'hui un texte qui est équilibré
qui est ambitieux et sur lequel nous
pourrons apporter nos suffrages sans
hésiter merci Jean de cessa
oui tout d'abord sur la forme monsieur
monsieur le Président c'est vrai
que si on tient pas compte de la
dernière demi-heure j'été plutôt content
du débat du fait que le rapporteur nous
explique à chaque fois prenne le temps
des explications et je dis à Monsieur le
Ministre que c'est normal de parler à la
représentation nationale de donner des
informations de de les aider à concevoir
le projet donc on peut penser que le
débat s'est plutôt bien déroulé je
regrette toutefois
qu'on ait quand même placé intercalé un
projet de loi auto-entrepreneur qui nous
a pas permis de de finir le débat dans
la semaine et d'être obligé de revenir
aujourd'hui je pense quand même qu'au
niveau de l'organisation on aurait pu
faire autrement alors lorsqu'on vient
sur le fond du sujet on parle du Grand
Paris et bien il y a trois conditions où
il y a on va dire que lorsqu'on parle du
Grand Paris il y a trois objectifs le
prier objectif du Grand Paris c'est
d'améliorer le réseau de transport on
sait très bien ça a été dit sur tous les
bancs ici qu'il y a que ce n'est plus
possible que les transports en commun
les transports collectif doivent être
davantage de qualité doivent être plus
nombreux et doivent irriguer l'ensemble
de
l'île-de-fance donc là à partir de là il
y avait une vraie analyse et on peut
dire que c'était utile mais ce n'est pas
pour autant que c'est le projet de la
grande bouque qui répond à ça il fallait
aider la région à concevoir un véritable
plan de transport et oui au volontarisme
pour améliorer les transports en
île-defance c'est le premier point
lorsqu'on parle du Grand Paris on veut
dire par là qu'il faut sortir du
périphérique Paris ville riche la
défense le département des Hautes scènes
département riches il y a des zones
dshéritées dans l'Île-de-France 93 dans
94 dans 77 et l'idée est quand même
d'homogénéiser de fait qu'il faut
résorber l'écart entre commune riche
commune pauvre il faut faire en sorte
d'intégrer les quartiers des hérités où
est ce projet aujourd'hui à quel moment
comment dans ce projet on peut dire
qu'il y a une volonté de résoudre les
inégalités territoriales les inégalités
sociales où est ce projet comment faire
la mise en œuvre absolument rien alors
maintenant on dit et là il y a deux
conceptions sans vouloir J qui que ce
soit ici dans cette assemblée il y a
ceux qui disent il faut
construire un grand métro un serpent de
terre pour que les hommes d'affaires
puissent communiquer entre eux puissent
se déplacer qu'il puisse y avoir des
stages qu'on puisse rejoindre l'aéroport
qu'on puisse lors de la cafétéria
discuter avec quelqu'un et d'un seul
coup hop on a une idée géniale bon c'est
et cette conception bon peu importe
comment elle est dite mais la conception
derrière c'est d'être compétitif
favoriser les hommes d'affaires qui se
regroupent favoriser les décideurs
économiques qui peuvent se rencontrer et
ainsi on sera en concurrence avec
shanghï londressite et puis il y a ceux
qui disent il faut concevoir la ville du
2 21e siècle autrement et et la ville du
21e siècle ce serait une ville de
comment vivre bien ensemble et là à
aucun moment on prévoit ça les gares
commerciales on sait pas comment va être
conçu les projets des architectes qui
avaient quand même cette idée d'une
unité territoriale de donner une
lisibilité au Grand Paris on n'en tient
pas compte et pour finir si on prend le
terme de Grand Paris c'est parce que
Paris exprime quelque chose partout dans
le monde lorsqu'on parle de Paris ça
signifie quelque chose est-ce que vous
croyez que c'est parce qu'on va faire un
métro que ça va améliorer l'image de
Paris un métro sous terre
à quel moment on valorise le patrimoine
de Paris à quel moment l'histoire de
Paris comment on peut dire que autour on
la répercute comment elle s'étend cette
histoire comment ce patrimoine des du 93
du 94 de l'ensemble des départements est
valorisé dans le Grand Paris ce n'est
absolument pas
posé et donc voilà pourquoi nous nous
voterons évidemment contre ce projet et
pour en finir sur la recherche et le
développement mais il y a pas qu'à Orset
qu'il faut faire la recherche et le
développement il est évident que la
société du 21e siècle c'est dans tous
les domaines qu'il faut de la recherche
et développement et la vraie question
qui est posée c'est comment dans Paris
même on favorise les étudiants comment
on favorise leur logement comment on
favorise leurs études comment on
favorise justement les cafétériats les
relation qui puissent avoir entre eux
aussi bien dans les cafétérias que dans
Internet que par le les stages qu'il
peuvent avoir et donc comment valorise
effectivement leur rentrée dans la dans
la vie comment on valorise le statut de
chercheur cette question là elle nous
concerne tous parce que nous sommes
persuadés qu'effectivement qu'il est
nécessaire de développer la recherche en
développement et pas simplement sur le
plateau de saclé mais dans l'ensemble de
l'île-de-fance et dans l'ensemble de
France bien merci Jean de cessard et la
parole à Monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues sous l'autorité bienveillante
du président etemorine que je tiens à
remercier et grâce aux explications
précises données par le ministre nous
avons consacré près de 40 he de séance
publique à ce texte je dis bien près de
40h outre les modifications adoptées en
commission spéciale sur lesquelles je ne
reviendrai
pas notre Assemblée a adopté sur les 306
amendements déposés une quarantaine
d'amendements dont 17 provenant de
l'opposition ce qui montre bien que il y
a eu débat il y a eu discussion il y a
eu correction d'un certain nombre
d'éléments du texte le texte issu de nos
travaux prévoit tout d'abord une
association plus étroite des élus de la
population et des architectes notamment
à travers la consultation de
parismétropole tant sur le schéma
d'ensemble du réseau de transport que
sur les contrats de développement
territorial qu'on aurait tort d'oublier
mon cher cèue èg et c'est pourquoi on ne
peut se satisfaire de ne s'occuper que
du métro le contrat de développement
territorial est à mon avis aussi
important que le grand métro afin de
conforter la place des élus locaux nous
avons également mieux encadré la
compétence d'aménagement de la Société
du Grand Paris en président en précisant
qu'elle ne pourra conduire des
opérations d'aménagement que dans un
rayon inférieur à 250 m autour des gares
du réseau de transport et au-delà il
faudra l'accord des collectivités
territoriales nous avons par ailleurs
complété les dispositifs financiers
adoptés en commission par deux avancées
importantes la possibilité pour la
région de lever au bénéfice du STIF une
taxe similaire à celle qu'avait créé la
Commission spéciale sur les plus-values
immobilières liées à la réalisation de
l'infrastructure et l'exonération de la
taxe des cessions réalisées au profit du
logement social enfin notre Assemblée a
souhaité que soit conçu un projet global
et cohérent à travers l'obligation
d'articuler le futur réseau de transport
du Grand Paris avec le réseau actuel en
parlant du maillage et en dégageant les
priorités tout en développant les modes
de transport alternatifs à la route le
fer et le fleuve afin de permettre la
relance des ports du Havre et de rouan
nous avons par ailleurs enrichi le volet
logement après l'adoption commission
spéciale de la la territorialisation par
le préfet de l'objectif de 70000
logements annuels inscrit à l'article
1er nous avons adopté en séance
l'article 19 TER précisant que les
communes soumises aux obligations de
construction de logements sociaux devont
intégrer de tels logements lorsqu'elles
réaliseront des opérations d'aménagement
auprès d'égard du futur réseau de
transport enfin nous avons ce soir
amélioré le volet relatif à sa clé avec
l'adoption com
d'un amendement sanctuirisant les 2300
hectares de terres agricoles sur le
plateau et un amendement prévoyant la
compétence de l'établissement public
Paris saclé en matière de couverture en
très haut débit et l'adoption cet
après-midi de l'amendement présenté par
nos collègues socialistes au terme
duquel le gouvernement devra remettre au
Parlement rapport présentant tous les 3
ans les prises de participation de
l'établissement public de Paris saclé
dans les entreprises
filiale groupement ou organisme nous
voilà donc parvenu mes chers collègues
au terme d'un débat danse riche un texte
sensiblement modifié par rapport à celui
que nous avons reçu de l'Assemblée
nationale il vise à conforter le projet
de Grand Paris et lui donner toutes les
chances de réussir mais nous avons
raisonné à 20 ans et non pas à 15 jours
et c'est cet élément de prospective qui
caractérise le passage au Sénat de ce
texte je tiens à remercier tous ceux qui
ont apporté leurs pierres à cet édifice
même si ces pierres étaient parfois un
peu aigu
et je forme le vœux qu'il apporte à nos
concitoyens les satisfactions qu'ils
sont en droit d'attendre merci monsieur
le rapporteur et la parole est au
président
jean-paulbrine merci monsieur le
Président messieurs les ministres
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs chers
collègues je crois qu'à C instant je
vais vous rappeler que j'ai présidé
cette commission spéciale sur le Grand
Paris et que pour moi c'était un moment
de redécouvrir Paris mais je vous ferai
part quand même que j'ai été un
observateur attentif si ce n'est dans
les relations avec vous monsieur le
ministre en vous auditionnant à la
Commission les relations que nous avons
pu avoir sur certains amendements et
aussi saluer jean-Pierre Fourcade pour
l'énorme travail qu'il a accompli parce
qu'en commission nous avons fait des
iudition à peu près 6 ou auditions de
commission et il a ouvert ces 50
auditions à l'ensemble des sénatrices et
sénateurs de la région parisienne je
crois que c'est pas quelque chose de
courant je crois que tout le monde a été
bien informé sur ce grand projet de loi
ce projet de loi pour moi est un très
grand projet puisqu'il permet quand même
à la région parisienne et vous l'avez
souvent souligné monsieur le ministre de
continuer être une région capitale
reconnue au niveau international et
c'est c'est et c'est bien un projet
national que nous avons examiné puisque
le provincial que je suis monsieur le
ministre chargé des Relations avec le
Parlement puisque je suis originaire de
la Bourgogne on ne peut pas être tous
originaires de la région parisienne mais
moi j'ai trouveré que c'était
véritablement un grand projet et les
travaux que le Sénat accomplit je vous
fais part de ce que j'ai pu observer ont
quand même apporté beaucoup de choses à
ce projet de loi tout le monde
s'inquiétait monsieur le ministre sur le
financement bien je crois que avec
l'appui du rapporteur et peut-être avec
beaucoup d'insistance vous êtes engagé
sur le financement de ce grand projet
vous pouvez hocher de la tête ma cher
collègue c'est ce que nous avons obtenu
au Sénat nous avons évoqué le logement
nous avons évoqué avec le président de
la SNCF les l'interconnexion des gardes
TGV autour des grands aéroports de la
région parisienne et puis quand monsieur
de cessar nous parle d'un métro
souterrain monsieur de cessar que dire
z-vous s'il était à ciel ouvert vous
nous diriez tout simplement qui perturbe
l'environnement de la région capitale
voilà à cet instant moi je voulais me
réjouir que tout le monde a participé à
ce projet de loi avec des approches
différentes mais la démocratie c'est ça
on peut avoir des approches différentes
mais moi je retiens c'est un très beau
projet pour notre pays un très beau
projet pour la région parisienne et
Monsieur le Ministre un grand merci
monsieur le rapporteur je pense que sans
vous qui avez qui aviez une bonne
connaissance de la région parisienne du
passé mais vous avez su tracer les
perspectives du futur et je vous en
remercie
alors j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe
UMP sur l'ensemble du projet de loi je
vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est
favorable l'avis du Gouvernement est
favorable il va être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour remettrons au
secrétaire un bulletin blanc contre un
bulletin bleu et l'abstention un
bulletin rouge le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instants le scrutin est
ouvert attention
plus personne ne demande à
voter le scrutin est clos et j'invite
Mesdames et Messieurs les secrétaires à
procéder au dépouillement du
scrutin
fait
la pration Pasu ah
I Je pas vu jeai pas
vu alors résultat du scrutin numéro 191
sur l'ensemble du projet de loi relatif
au Grand Paris nombre de votants
337 nombre de suffrages exprimés
332 majorité absolue des suffrages
exprimés
167 pour l'adoption
179 contre
153 le Sénat a adopté l'ensemble du
projet de
loi c'est la fin de cette séance pour la
revoir notre site internet publsenat.fr
bonne journée à tous sur notre
antenne